[Music]
okay
[Applause]
welcome to fatman beyond i'm kevin smith
hey
thank you so much we are here at smod
castle and leonardo just down the strip
maybe we i didn't i haven't timed it
or measured it yet but i would say it's
like
25 [ __ ] steps uh to quick stop
convenience where we made that movie
that nobody ever heard about
um thank you for coming out tonight just
a
a a piece of info for the folks watching
uh on youtube or facebook
uh everyone in the audience is masked
and you know if everybody's sitting at
home it's like what the [ __ ] did you
read the new cdc guidelines and [ __ ]
they say if you're vaccinated
i absolutely agree with you
unfortunately with the movie
we have a very tight insurance policy
particularly when it comes to covet
we have a coveted cop on our movie who
wields
more power than i do like i'm really
looking forward to when i'm like
cut and he's like not yet you know and
[ __ ] like that
so basically we had a big meeting with
him this week and boy oh boy did he put
the fear of god into us because he was
like look
one person gets coveted the whole
production gets shut down for [ __ ] 10
days and that's not colgate that's
a covet like you know uh test is
positive and [ __ ]
and we're you know our budget's nice but
it's not nice enough to like [ __ ] off
for 10 days as if we're tom cruise and
mission impossible whatever
and unlike tom cruise i'm not the kind
of guy that wants to scream at [ __ ]
on set being like
we're saving the industry you [ __ ] put
on a mask and then run real [ __ ] fast
so uh we asked the audience tonight to
keep masks on since great for them not
well
everyone knows he's gonna be on the show
since our guest and i tonight
won't be boring mast i thank you all for
doing it um
i've been trying to make this movie for
seven [ __ ] years
uh they just announced it this week and
stuff that we're making it but
i i i would hate to be the guy that shut
production down man that would [ __ ]
eat it so hard if i was just like
we finally did it and they're like wait
a second you're sick because you did fat
man beyond i'm like
so thank you for staying masked for the
show um
i uh just a piece of personal
information kids uh it's
7 35 i uh this is trigger warning
for anyone who may have an eating
disorder
this is for mostly the folks at the
youtube audience or anyone here
in the room because i've posted about
this in the past
and some people get really like wigged
out about it and stuff
um so if you're wigged out about eating
issues and stuff maybe
mute or whatever the [ __ ] uh that being
said
uh i just finished a seven day
fast i have not eaten since the like
after
we did fat man beyond last week um and
it was amazing i feel fantastic
i'm all [ __ ] cleaned out and [ __ ]
like that but
i had right before i came here i had a
bowl of tomato soup
and you would have thought like i got to
you know
[ __ ] bo derek in the 80s or something
like that
it was like the most delicious [ __ ]
bowl
of soup i've ever had and when i'm
eating or feeding i
you know i just [ __ ] i've obviously
got weight control issues and stuff
so when i eat i'll just turn it on and
eat for like hours straight and [ __ ]
feed and graze and stuff like that
so i'd stop appreciating the taste or
joy of food because i'm just forcing it
in and stuff
being that i hadn't had anything for
like seven days that soup was
[ __ ] sumptuous man it was so
incredible and it came off the [ __ ]
shelf at whole foods it was like no big
thing but oh my god that's what gave me
the energy to come here tonight and
since i haven't had anything for a while
that [ __ ] bowl of soup has been wired
man
so it's gonna be a very [ __ ] lively
show um and then when the show is over
i'm gonna go have a falafel
uh rap none of this sounds [ __ ] sexy
right like
somebody's like if i if i didn't eat for
seven days i need something [ __ ] cool
and i'm like i'm gonna have some hummus
and soup i sound like an 80 year old
[ __ ] man
uh but it works it works very good i was
trying to uh kind of get
tight or tighter i should say for uh
for the playing silent bob i wanted to
look like uh i did in clerks uh
i'm sorry in uh jane's reboot and so i
do i now hit the weight that i was uh
weighed when we were making the movie so
we're off to the races and [ __ ]
um that all being said we got guests
with us
kids um our guest tonight uh
is a cat who's been acting for a while
have you ever watched amazon's the tick
he was arthur a perfect arthur if you
know the comic book
um but for us he gave us the heart
and the soul of this show if you've seen
masters of the universe of revelation if
you're watching at home and you haven't
seen it
going to be a lot of spoilers kids so
many spoilers tonight
um if you've seen massive universal
revelation love it or hate it and i've
heard a few people
don't like it
i will talk about that later um whether
you like it or not
anyone has to agree one of the best
performances
in the entire show and one of the best
characters hands down winds up being
orco
and we wouldn't get have gotten there uh
without
uh our soulful actor tonight who's one
of the funniest people i've ever worked
with
we only met today for the first time in
person all the work we did
on revelations was over like he was in
new york we were in california so we did
it over
zoom he was in a studio um and then i
was on
a show he does called the george lucas
talk show
and we did that virtual as well so when
i met him at the
secret stash today we've been having the
revelation celebration
sold out on saturday and sunday where a
bunch of people come and take pictures
they get stuff
um when he came down to the stash that
was first time i got to like
lay hands on the guy which sounds
[ __ ] dirtier than i meant to but you
know what i mean like
this person has become so [ __ ]
important to my body of work man
and this was the first time i got to see
him it may be the first time a lot of
you
get to see him tonight uh give it up for
perhaps the greatest orco
you'll ever know at least in my opinion
the great griffin newman ladies guns
uh when you say one of the funniest
people you've ever worked with
i'm just trying to come up with a
relative scale here uh
below muse but above lee what are we
what do we think
yeah oh my god yeah i have affleck being
easily i know because affleck works too
hard
that's what you're saying his comedy's
too thirsty
yes yes he is a thirsty comic he wants
it too badly he and does he not have
enough at this point i asked i know it
[ __ ] bugs me so much that he's so
beautiful so kind so [ __ ] rich
so [ __ ] talented and and like he gets
everything
yeah it's like can't you have that one
[ __ ] lane man but he has
everything some of us out here have not
even dated jlo
once we are still waiting
for our first at-bat and he's
circling back around for seconds um
uh give me such a kind introduction i
hate to come out and
come in critical but i i do feel like i
need to offer a little bit of
constructive criticism fair enough
uh uh he-man beyond yes i get it the
show's called
uh fat me and beyonce yes you've
replaced he
the fat topical the new show
yes i get it okay i do feel like there's
a missed opportunity
oh this show used to be called
uh fat man batman and this was an
opportunity
to call this show fat man on he-man no
new man on he-man
what was it new man on he-man oh you've
got a man as well yeah i do
anyway welcome to he-man beyond
[Music]
mark bernard will be back next week
ladies and gentlemen and
he never [ __ ] springs on me like that
um let me tell you something about uh
griffin here
excuse me this is drinking this um
griffin his performance of of orco
is one of my favorite for obviously for
what he does with it and stuff
but this is what i always love to know
in the original he-man and the masters
of the universe uh
from filmation orco
was voiced by lou scheimer uh one of the
one of the producer scheimer
he was the head of the animation company
yeah so he would record his voice
and then they'd put it through a filter
and dial it up so it could be high and
stuff like that
so when he recorded it he just sounded
like a guy and then they pitched it
to sound like working so if you went up
to him
you know with your kid and you were like
this is orco and the kid was like be
orco he'd be like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about like you know come to a
lab with me so they can dial my voice up
and down and put it through a filter
then you'll hear work though when we
were doing this
griffin didn't like if you watch the
show there's no
filter on his voice he can just
do that voice he found it and i watched
him for like so many sessions on on a
zoom monitor
sit there and sometimes hold his throat
like this
and like do this amazing performance
that if you met him in real life and you
had your kid and you were like this is
orco he could literally do
orgo for the kid and that was always my
theory you know i was like oh that would
be so sweet
the theory tested out today when we did
the revelation celebration of the secret
stash
we had a lot of kids come in uh more
kids than we've ever had in the stash
before
because we offered like a free toy to
kids like 10 and under men and [ __ ]
kids love
free so they came up and so he got
to do it you got to do the orca voice
live for somebody
the thing that was great was the it was
one of the first kids in the morning
asked is that you don't want to say hey
i can't
i can do whatever you want because then
the parents go like why are you trying
so hard to impress my kid
but there was yeah they're like that's a
little [ __ ] suspect orco
it was it was the moment i've been
waiting for by the way i have zero chill
what kevin's not telling you
is in the first session when i did the
voice myself and he went that's
impressive and i went
well yeah i spent two months working on
it because someday i want to be able to
tell a kid that i'm the voice of oracle
and then do it in person like
someone who is actually cool would just
do and go like oh man you know i never
even thought about that
i thought about it i thought about it
way too much but
you lobbied for the gig really hard
really hard like
on twitter he was not just him tweeting
about it going like i really want this
part
which is very rare for any
established actor and you're an
established actor this guy with a career
he's been in stuff
questionable look on sure but there he
is kind of putting his heart on his
sleeve
yeah going like i i really like i'm
telling you i'm the right person to play
this part
and so eventually like it penetrated
because there were other people
signal boosting you going like [ __ ]
you this guy's amazing i was working
multiple angles i mean now i'm on the
other end of it you can't
fire me so i i can sort of spill some of
this yes let's
fill the teeth uh eric carrasso who's
one of the great writers on the show
eric wrote episode five um
he's and he wrote uh you'll see episodes
six and ten i co-wrote six with him
um he's a wonderful writer came from the
world of supergirl that's where i met
him he wrote one of my episodes
um and now he's doing a huge [ __ ]
show that we can't
say it's very secret but very large
messy um
uh he will soon be able to buy all of us
yeah um for sport
um uh eric
uh and i have a mutual friend named
derek simon who's my oldest friend
uh i met when i was nine years old
everyone before that
[ __ ] lightweight i i didn't keep up
with them yeah derek's the old guy
yeah that's the oldest one i kept was
that somewhere watching the audience
with somebody at the beginning like oh
griffin i loved him when i was a kid
i traded on that second i met derek i
cut the fat
i'm no derek yeah uh derek simon is a
writer and supergirl as well so he and
eric
work together derek and eric derek and
eric [ __ ] there's a sitcom
absolutely um and so
uh he and i have known each other
forever and we bonded over we went to
uh a day camp together where i'm getting
too much backstory here we went to take
i just think people if this
venue will appreciate this story uh we
went to a day camp together that was an
arts camp
but they made you go to the pool in the
middle of the day
and you were doing arts but they were
like everybody stopped no you have to do
one normal kid thing a day get in the
[ __ ] pool and there and i were like
we are
never taking our shirts off
so we for two i know i am now as an
adult i don't even take my shirt off in
the [ __ ] shower
absolutely uh two successive summers we
ran the oh my god i forgot to pack a
bathing suit you can't make me go in
khan
and they would go okay well then the one
thing you can do
is sit on the dirt in this area we need
to be able to look at you visually
and there's only this much dirt around
the pool so just sit
there and we would just sit there and
talk about x-men and that's how we
became friends
uh so a lot of our nerd phases have gone
through things together
we got uh into your movies together and
uh
he knew that i was very very into he-man
which was
he he picked other things but he man was
like my ballywood for a number of years
there
so eric when you hire him onto the show
reached out to derek and goes uh he-man
i got hired this is a big
thing and i know as we have all learned
uh he-man fans are
very opinionated so he's like i gotta
know i cuz
i'm a fan but i'm not a mega fan i wanna
know what the expectations are what
would a fan want to see
right uh eric's like a huge dc fan so he
gets hired on supergirl he writes a
bunch of the animated movies he knows he
has that fan brain in his head
i can write to me right but with he-man
he said i want to talk to someone who's
really hardcore about this
and derek talk to griff so i get on the
phone with eric on like a random weekday
evening and we talked for like an hour
and i was like look this is what i've
always liked about it
it's this i like the messiness all these
different pieces all the the
at the end of the conversation he goes
what do you think of oracle and i go
look work those devices
half the people love a worker that was
their favorite character growing up half
the people hated working
half the people liked oracle when they
were little and then pretended they
hated them because it wasn't cool
anymore
you know it goes through things some
people think he's c3po some people think
he's jar jar
he's either essential or he's beyond
expendable
right and i said but i think he's
essential i think he's important i think
yeah
and he went okay because you know i just
was thinking wantonly
you would be a good orca and i went
don't [ __ ] say it too loudly but yeah
obviously that's what i'm just thinking
i would be a good orca
so then he's in the room with you now
right he started whispering
you know that newman kid the bunny ears
next to the tick
he did a total iago whispered in my hair
he was the christian
but then diametra who also gets hired
onto your writer's staff she was
the one she wrote episode two boys yes
she was the writer's assistant on the
first season of the tech oh is that
right
so she's also starting to whisper make
it seem like it's independent thought no
it's coordinated
look at you it's coordinated i was
catfished yup and then the two of them
tell me
hey teddy this is the executive at
netflix
that's the guy who's also going to be
able to put his thumb on the scale
we know you're a big [ __ ] dork
you like action figures and [ __ ] right
this guy they're saying that to me but
they're like this guy's even bigger
[ __ ] action figure dork than you are
teddy is he has all of his original
figures the entire collections
and they're out of boxes and they're
mounted on shelves and not mounted like
they're glued to the shop
he just has them standing perfectly
although we live in earthquake country
out there
and he said that like i've gone through
four earthquakes and one time um
only one figure one skeletor fell he's
like but i put him up everything's fine
but he's got rooms dedicated to this
[ __ ] like he
he he's forgotten more about masters
universe than anyone will ever know
truly and he has like the the european
only releases he has everything in
perfect condition
uh and he's this incredibly artistic guy
he started out in stop-motion animation
before he became an executive
he did stop motion well so this is i
know he did voiceover as well
this is what i found out he did a loki
once in one of the martial
cartoons yes so so dia and eric were
like
you gotta appeal to teddy on the action
figure front
so i start following him and then we
start dming about like what are you
looking for you buy this recently
the the next time in l.a hey look let's
go meet up and we just nerd out about
stuff
i hear his whole story which is that he
went to school for animation he was a
stop-motion guy people start asking him
in other classes hey can you fill in a
voice
his voices are so good that people start
hiring him professionally then he moves
up the ranks and comes this executive
now is the guy who gets to pick which
cartoons end up on uh netflix and
thus the only place that live action
stuff live action as well
sweet sweet tooth yes and the dark
crystal series which was amazing there's
a lot of a lot of stuff in netflix uh
all the good
geeky stuff at netflix um but he's got
this instagram that is
uh you know his amazing stop-motion
background
do you ever see you go we'll do it right
now yeah particularly if you're at home
animated
animate it's spelled like animated but
you have to
know that his name is ted um and he
builds
like sets for these uh
that he i mean this is a guy who's like
real high up at netflix and like is
always overseeing
10 20 if not 30 projects but like still
every day takes time to like set up his
figures light that [ __ ]
he put smoke and fog
he's put more work in these pictures
than i ever put into one of my motion
it's wild it's wild it's truly what so i
was talking about all that and then i
just said at the end of it by the way
you know my senior norco tape last week
keep your ears open for that so i just
was trying to make sure
i know at the end of the day way to game
the system i really did
uh but but then this is the problem i
can only reveal this to you now because
at the moment you've been like this guy
is so
[ __ ] desperate yeah someone get him a
date
what is this it's putting all of this
energy into work
more like it would have been like he's
trying to get to us too badly man that
guy has a [ __ ]
gun yeah
yeah uh you're the absolute [ __ ]
right choice though even like when we
heard all the auditions we heard other
people do orco
um and all of them did a good job
he did a great job and as soon as we got
you in front of the mic
for the with the real lines of the show
yeah oh [ __ ]
it was absolute magic your scenes with
lena are incredible and you never met
you've never even recorded method no and
we were saying that today i was like
i'm god our chemistry is good it's like
i don't know her
yeah at all because you could walk up to
her to place and be like we've worked
together and she's like you're out of
your mind
absolutely i don't work with people who
look like you are you too little right
yes
um no but i mean to go full circle
uh uh you know i work so hard to sort of
uh get on the radar for this right and
then i finally go to my reps i go please
let's stay on this
uh let's get an audition they send me
the script pages and then i go
[ __ ] well now i have to figure out how
to do it right how do i do this voice
and the conundrum is that lou scheimer
was mostly doing it through
post-production and the back story that
is
lou schemer was the head of film nation
the film nation's uh
competitive advantage was that they were
really [ __ ] cheap they were really
good at producing animation
on the cheap there are all sorts of
techniques they used re using things
flipping the image so you could get it
in both directions
all this sorts of [ __ ] but the other
thing that that you don't know as a man
who just
did a big fancy schmancy animated show
is that the union rules are such that i
think you were allowed to
have any voice actor do up to three
voices without paying them extra
very true and then when you go over
three the salary increases
that's why jerk vader did both king
randor
and um trap jaw as well right because
you're just double dipping doesn't cost
you anything extra if you got a guy
there who can do more than one voice
uh would but i could so um
uh shimer was trying to keep his budgets
down and so they could only afford to
hire like
four or five actors and you can only get
two or three voices out of each of them
and then other characters appear right
and so his
solution was i will take every
additional
male role under a pseudonym and not pay
myself
and every additional female role will go
till my teenage daughter
under suited him and not pay her that
was how they did it that's how they did
it and so orco which is one of the only
characters on the show
this is not true one of the only main
characters on the show that was not
part of the toy line first that was
created filmation 81
in 81 the toy line comes out masters of
the universe and that's
technically what we're closest related
to revelation we use all their
lore all their backstory because they
wrote bunches and bunches of them and
stuff
um but uh it wasn't until 83
excuse me that they start he-man in the
massive universe
that's where orco is created right so
shimer was personally invested in
creating
and then does the voice for it but his
main goal is
i gotta do like 8 000 [ __ ] voices on
the show i gotta make sure they sound
different
you know so he's running his voice
through a thousand filters because
people can't realize that that versus
the same as the other guy who's on
screen at the same time so i'm
here in the present day trying to
reverse engineer a voice that came out
of practical logistics right
and i can't find any recording of what
lou shimer
sounded like that i found like one video
of him doing an interview i'm like he
sounds like a guy
i don't know what his voice was in the
room before they run it through that
filter in my audition i'm in my closet
and i'm downloading apps and going like
chipmunk voice is that what it is and
then trying that
and i got to this thing where i was like
the only way to make it
sound right in post is if i'm talking
like
like adam come on what are you doing
here am i right there hey adam what are
you doing
but it feels weird as an actor when
you're going like them i don't got any
magic left
you know you know now that i hear it we
should have done that version
of the show might have gone over better
with some pants yeah but it's hard to
get in the feels because
as it's coming out of your mouth you're
like that sounds wrong right right
uh and so i sent in two takes one each
way
and then didn't know whether you were
going to want to
run it through all those filters because
of continuity and tradition all that
but from the moment i got the roll there
was maybe like two or three more months
before we started recording and i was
like i'm just going to [ __ ] run this
every single night in my bathroom like
before i go to sleep i brush my teeth
and i do my like orco scales and see if
i can get up there
i guarantee you no other actor on the
show did that
like you really poured your heart into
well no other actor had to
figure out how to replicate auto-tune
with their throat
everyone else had a normal voice but but
yes i i really i really
did and it was a lot of it came from the
fact that he was this character that was
divisive and
you and i talked about this from the
very beginning i know you talked about
this with your writers but you went like
we got to make oracle work like that's
sort of like
it's a it's a personal challenge where
it's like
you don't wanna the marching orders we
had in the room yeah
was let's make orkos so cool
people get them tattooed on their body
did you see the woman today
yes there was a woman today who came
into the secret stash for a
revelation celebration and she had a
pretty fresh
pretty fast or go tattoo and i was like
get out of here and she's like when i
saw the trailer i was in
and then there was a tweet uh that i
texted you last
night yeah as well um that was somebody
going like well that's
it i'm getting an orca tattoo and i was
like mission but it was like angry the
text was like oh you [ __ ] guys i
guess i gotta get an oracle
tattoo it was like very resentful let me
tell you
of all the angry tweets that was the
last one
that's the best one i've seen way
angrier tweets than that
uh but but you know i think the
challenge is that like
we didn't want to make we didn't want to
cater to the people who disliked oracle
at the expense of the people who've
always loved to work
you got to make an oracle that's still
in line with everything for everyone
who's been there on his side
and then you also additionally want to
break down the defenses of everyone who
was like why can't this guy just learn
how to do a magic trick
step one of that is you know weakening
them
like when we first we first meet them
it's like in the first episode
might as well be an episode of the old
show yeah it's just the same old orca
next time we meet him in episode three
he's you know
on the verge of losing everything his
health is
is connected to magic so he's very
weakened so once you take him to that
stat
stage you know then people are like all
right i used to hate this guy but he's
dying at least
you know or something like that yeah
then once he starts
i'm telling you you gotta be a [ __ ]
robot or a computer
to not [ __ ] get emotional when you
give that little speech where you're
like please
just take me on an adventure even roboto
got worked up
right there let's see resting up the
gears no but i i think um
i don't remember if we said this to you
early on but even like with with the
the tick which was similar uh similarly
a thing where i was
a huge fan of it for decades and
wow there's a new tick no chance they're
going to hire me they're going to want
to get [ __ ] tofu grace or something
but like i gotta do that is that your
[ __ ] lex luthor and acting no i have
other more direct i'm taking a more
distant shot rather than the people who
i actually see in the waiting rooms
is so who is your acting lex luthor i
mean the [ __ ] big head on silicon
valley who's great
that really he's great but yeah i mean i
feel like he's one of them
there's a collection of them um a bunch
of rogues who keep you from getting
parts
yeah yeah other jittery little man
[Laughter]
that goes on a tombstone here here lies
a jittery little man
finally may he sit still um
but but uh i i the the thing
you know and this is sort of when i when
i met with teddy and sort of talked
about [ __ ] with him i tried to do the
same thing which was like
i'm not gonna sell you online the best
actor for the role i'm gonna just try to
let you know what i think about this
character and
and i try to convey the depth of the
thought i put into this guy
but when um i was sort of in the running
for the tick and everyone else
who was in consideration had been the
star of a tv show before and i was
nobody uh i was a person fired from tv
shows before
and i met with him and i just said like
look my whole thing is that
and i'm sorry i've got a tangent but i i
think there's a lot of linkage between
orco and arthur and they're both
characters i grew up loved
agreed and i went the thing i love about
arthur is that there's
no uh bravado right there's no machismo
to this guy
um he is genuinely driven to do the
right thing because his moral compass is
that strong
despite the fact that he cannot even
hide that he is
terrified right arthur has no
performative mode right he doesn't even
have an alter ego he
forgot to come up with a fake superhero
name right so he's clark
kent but actually clark kent all the
time even when he's on the front lines
of the battle
and i think there's something really
brave to the fact that he is that
scared that he's not someone who feels
empowered enough to know like i think i
got this i used to be weak but then that
spider bite now i'm [ __ ] set
right he's like i'm gonna die i'm gonna
die at all times but i'd rather die
trying to do the right thing
and the thing i said to ben was like
it's the thing
i love about as a kid my favorite
goddamn character of all time is fozzie
bear
because every time it would just be
fozzie backstage to currently
i really think i'm going to get it this
time i really think this is the act
that's going to play in criminals like
posi this is a bad idea
i'm warning you your concept is sweaty
this act is not going to translate and
he goes like i
really think it's going to work and he
goes out there and of course that
learned world or
immediately go like this [ __ ] sucks
and there would always be that moment
every fozzy bear routine where he'd sort
of just look at him and go like please
guys i'm trying really hard here
that he wouldn't even try to like roast
the crowd or fight back or whatever he'd
just be like come on man i really
i'd love to get a laugh here and that
it's that same thing with orco for me
where it's like he's
always failing every goddamn trick fails
and yet every time he shows up and he's
like a magic trick for the palace and
it's like
when orco don't do it he's like no this
one's gonna work
you know and that kind of thing which i
still impresses me that you just [ __ ]
dropped the voice
like
what what it's gonna be like for the
next person to [ __ ] you you use that
voice
uh what's orko's oh face well i mean
first of all he barely has a face and
he's got an o on his chest
so i think he maybe just points and goes
oh
but but i think yes i think that's the
very smart thing uh
you guys did as writers is that you gave
him that moment that
it was always this trick's gonna work
trick fails
well i blew it right that you have that
moment of him pleading
and there were many moments where we
were in the recording booth and i would
uh it wasn't acting it was just
cold reading the script pages because
you know you're rewriting stuff all the
time i've read the scripts when the new
stuff comes in
and just reading through it for the
first time i would get genuinely choked
up because it's just so
sweet and earnest there's no ulterior
motive with this guy he's the kid's way
in he was
kid's way in back in 83. right he's the
character that any kid can identify you
aspire to be human
right but you can identify with workouts
right i'm tiny no one takes me seriously
i get everything wrong
right and i want to be i want to go can
i be involved like i'll be good
i'm as good as you can but that's that's
the moment you guys writing that moment
when she goes like please please why am
i not doing the voicemail
let me go on one more adventure please
you know where it's like
i feel like that's gonna break down the
heart of anyone who is
cynical about oracle before because it's
like oh god he really cares i can't just
go like this guy's annoying anymore i
understand
the personal stakes for him and how much
he's heeded not
seeing these people for years you know
he missed them
he really did you know what approved
that [ __ ] uh even jar jar can be
redeemed
i look i i want to say this i uh
uh i have a podcast i do call blank
check and that podcast came
out of my friends has anyone heard
blackjack before
thank you from those at home who haven't
explained the premise
it's wonderful well so i mean the
premise now as it stands is we pick a
director who we think at some point
david sims esteemed film critic for the
atlantic
and new jersey's own ben hosley aka
producer ben aka 18 more nicknames
uh who is actually here in attendance
tonight not to blow up his spot
but um we pick a director who we think
at some point got
a blank check status uh and explained
black checks
well like you post clerks where people
go kevin smith that's the thing i get
what it is
here take a bunch of money go to a mall
make a movie right
and your career goes through these peaks
and valleys every director wants to get
to that point where people go i get what
your thing is you've proven it you found
your audience
now go out and do it again right and
people take swings and they either
you know they go up they go down all the
sort of stuff my
my friend dave and i were always just
fascinated we became
friends through going to a movie trivia
night together and we would just sit
there and go like
what what was that guy's career and we
pulled by into being like
right he made that and then that like
the order of it fascinated fall down the
rabbit hole right
so it's like oh wait so wait it's that's
a reaction to this
you know um but the first year of the
show
and so what you do when you do a
director one movie at a time one episode
of time the whole filmography
is that right yeah so like we're we're
starting john carpenter in two weeks and
that will take us to the end of the year
we spend many months with carpenter
because that's how
many more 20 20 do you also do elvis tv
movie
we will do that on patreon that's what
we call bonus content my friends
look at that yeah oh is that right
absolutely [ __ ] because no wonder you
were so insidious about getting into the
show man
you know how you got this thing yeah
right genius that's
what other directors do you do the bonus
uh well
were there other directors that you were
like we ain't doing this on the main
show
uh the bonus we do um
we'll do uh franchises rather than
directors so a franchise that maybe had
a lot of people work on it didn't have
one formal sort of auteur behind it
and we'll do those episodes and then one
of the three episodes on patreon a month
is some sort of bonus grab bag thing so
if there's something like that in the
career
oh they did a tv thing there's a thing
they maybe wrote or didn't direct or
whatever it feels connected
maybe there's a sequel or a remake to
one of their movies like anything that's
not proud of
a part of the proper theatrical canon
and sometimes we just do stupid [ __ ]
we've done two episodes where we
literally just watch studio logos
and go like yeah i think 75 was the best
year for warner brothers
and people like it i mean we just keep
on going like look we'll have these
conversations
either way if you want us to record them
you can listen to them right
we used to think these were the
conversations that made other people
walk away from us
right but you know you find the one
person in each town who's like i wanted
to have that conversation with somebody
uh all this a long-winded way to say
that the first year of our show what it
came out of was
we had this very stupid idea that was uh
everyone talks about how much they hate
the phantom menace the thing that now
people forget and think that
people only start being mad about star
wars five years ago uh
weird the way that uh we are bound to uh
repeat
the mistakes of history when we forget
them but um
if they ask the whole thing was everyone
saying that as you said as everyone said
just like well this is the thing the
original movies got right and phantom
ass gets wrong
right and we had this sort of thought
experiment of like what if you pretended
phantom menace was
what phantom ass is pretending to be the
first movie in a franchise
you were watching it without any of that
[ __ ] baggage and you're just taking
its own merits
and we had this dumb bit of what if we
did a podcast where every single week
the only movie we watched and talked
about was the phantom menace
and we treated it like it was jupiter
ascendant like it was the first movie in
a franchise that just
too bad no one showed up didn't work out
who knows what he would have done
right and all the foreshadowing all the
time you know you just you're looking at
its own and producer ben went uh we went
he went how how long is the show going
around for and we went like years what
do you thought i would never run out of
material i'll give you ten weeks
so we did the show and then uh at the
end of 10 weeks there was a huge twist
we found out that in fact
somehow under our very noses george
lucas had made a second phantom menace
movie
what i know it's called pack of the
clones this thing [ __ ] came out of
yours i never
heard of it no bids but we did that for
like a year and then we ran out of star
wars movies we
was this [ __ ] thing we realized over
the course of doing it oh we were more
interested in george lucas trying to
figure out what george lucas was chasing
you know uh not chasing amy but like
what was driving this guy at any
given moment yeah and then how do you
explain from dhx1138 to america
right 3d to star wars right and uh
because we did have a workforce we later
corrected and did th x american group
video on patreon
so um the uh way we spent a lot of time
on campus is the point and jar jar for
me
the humongous missed opportunity with
jar jar binks for me
okay is that george lucas clearly loved
jar jar right i think he really
really thought the public was gonna
[ __ ] adore this thing
right and there are all those interviews
you see behind the scenes where he's
like the key to this whole movie is drug
drug
we figure out jar jar the movie works
that's like well that's maybe the
problem you're betting on the wrong
course
but it was all about geography for him
and then
it comes out everyone sits on jar jar
and he's like never mind jar jar has
nothing to do with anything
right second movie he's in it for one
scene he goes like meets a vote yay and
everyone
you know third movie he sheds it's here
silent he didn't get a line he doesn't
get residuals for that movie right he's
a featured extra
um and for me i was just like the
greatest missed opportunity
is that he didn't give jar jar a
meaningful death right it's a prequel
we understand that things are going to
go bad we know the status quo that we
have to get to
yeah by the end of revenge of the sith
or at least leading up to
let jar jar die a hero let him have a
noble sacrifice and
make everyone who disliked jar jar feel
like an [ __ ] and i just like jar jar
and i
wanted him to rub that in my [ __ ]
face you know you're like i'll pay you
to [ __ ] make me rethink all this [ __ ]
right right it's like
the guy in your friend group who you
hate and he does you a big solidarity i
guess greg is cool
you know and somewhere greg's watching
going that's how he feels about me right
yeah no offense greg but like even if
it's not death it's like
george or harrison means something and
instead they make jar jar the villain
he's the guy who cowardly votes in favor
of the palpatine thing and it felt like
an easy way out you know
and it's it's the order thing of just
like
make what he does mean something and and
just [ __ ] test the cynicism of the
people who think that they're too cool
for orgo
you know and i see people like you know
uh
you've alluded to it several times
tonight but the people who are uh
uh addicted to being angry online that
that there was this whole thing about
like
oh kevin killed oracle because he hates
orco and he wants to punish the oracle
fans
and it's like no the idea was to make
orco
mean something and also
we all know especially in sci-fi and
fantasy
if a character is dead they are dead
forever and there is no way they can
ever come back
so we should honestly take this very
seriously as the
final time we will ever see orco that's
the one that like
like i honestly i'll i can kind of get
when people are like oh i wanted
like more he-man in this show and
whatnot you know i i want to say like oh
just [ __ ] wait right like
episode i'm not should i and [ __ ] why
not
let's say episode six goes hard episode
six at the end of episode six we do
something that they've
never done in the franchise before
you're going to get more xenon than you
think you
want it and epi like episode 7
contains no [ __ ] and you know i know
i'm going to say this and then a very
very vocal contingency of the internet
is going to say i'm
lying apologize my tone
baiting and switching or something like
that but i promise you on my
child's life um in episode 7
there is a skeletor and spoilers
hey man fight that tops
anything that's one of the most brutal
[ __ ] fights i've seen
the only brutal fight in animation i've
seen more brutal
was invincible when he [ __ ] held his
kid through the trains and [ __ ]
which to be fair was good parenting but
yeah
but very brutal very bloody and stuff we
don't you know
ours is not doesn't take it to that
place but between these two characters
it is it's so [ __ ] up pat and adam our
directors
you know we wrote like they fight and
it's not skeletor it's skelet god
because as we know he gets the power and
[ __ ]
and you know we have this uh we do this
thing
and so we wrote about like they fight
pat and adam
did this brilliant [ __ ] sequence that
goes on for seven minutes where they
just
beat the [ __ ] out of each other in like
insanely entertaining ways using magic
using [ __ ] bare fists and [ __ ] um at
one point they grabbed fists off of
bears and used them
so at one point he um
you know there's original drawing of uh
he-man the original
first drawing of him um he's got like an
axe and a [ __ ] shield and he looks
very cony and likes the character
was very much derived from conan i'm
sure you've seen the toys that made us
masters of the universe episode but they
were going to make conan toys and then
they saw conan and they're like there's
[ __ ]
boobies in this and so they decided to
make something a little more
kid-friendly
and that's what master of the universe
became and stuff so
there's uh yeah there's
the image that they first drew of the
character
like we get to incorporate we we try
like we just that's why i like when
people like you're not a he-man fan i'm
like yeah right
cuts are so goddamn deep in this show
that it's like
i would say this is non-antagonistically
as possible yeah people can dislike the
show
that is obviously a legal opinion oh my
god
for the guy who made [ __ ] yoga hosers
i'm used to that
i have no problem with people being like
are you sucking this [ __ ] sucks
that's
fine but like the the thing you know it
it goes deep it goes hard this was the
other thing i was going to say
like the tick was a show that got
canceled prematurely right
did it unfortunately yeah if you i mean
i didn't get to buy a beach house so
yeah that's pretty sure uh
i'm just kidding i hate the beach um we
did we did two seasons and
you know i bring this up because in this
streaming era i think we're all used to
people going
got that we had the whole thing planned
as a five season arc
and then they drop it after two seasons
and you're left with blue balls and it's
unresolved right
and that was certainly a thing where
bennett linking many wouldn't season
three is this we're gonna introduce this
and like
people were saying why aren't you taking
chair face chippendale and all these
characters from the comics and bringing
me well we're working up to that
and then we never got to work up to that
and people are frustrated and i get it
you know you had an aborted plan
uh and then you feel like well i wasted
all this time getting into something
not that it's wasting time the first two
seasons of the ticker very excellent you
should watch him please
uh but uh there's that kind of thing and
i think that i
have been trying to communicate as much
as possible anytime i have a microphone
in front of my
stupid face is that uh 10 episodes were
written
all at once netflix has chosen to
release them in two batches
this isn't the thing where it's like
well we hope you get a sec
no yeah revelation 10 episodes right and
and the back five are done
right bear just finished the score for
episode 10 with his live orchestra and
stuff and it sounds [ __ ] astounding
now that his score is done we're
finished and adam have
sent in every [ __ ] shot it's locked
so it's
finished i know some people online are
like you ain't coming back this shit's
getting killed
it's like in the can yeah right it can't
not come out right and not only that
it was ten episodes all written one big
story
right and it's like a story that
certainly leaves the door open for more
adventures but i think tells a complete
satisfying story in relation to a
perfect
world they would have released all 10. i
[ __ ] and i'm happy they released them
the way they did especially because 5 is
such a great cliffhanger
but in a perfect world they released all
10. and i'm not saying that would have
assuaged
everybody there would definitely be some
people that are still like [ __ ] so
you're kind of clicking up the roller
coaster last five years we had done all
five
then the thing that everyone's crying
about the most and we're like where the
[ __ ] is
like this has been the only thing that's
frustrating to me
again i don't mind if people like you
[ __ ] suck and it sucks like i'm used
to that but
in some ways it just feels like some of
these people have never seen
a tv program or a movie yes ever
well this is the thing that's the idea
the idea of like
you of orco yeah like not i'm not trying
to telegraph anything
just bear with me kids if you watch
that episode episode four with orco and
we see what orgo does and stuff
it is very close to um
another uh magic figure in
fiction who also gives his life
uh in a very important moment in the
story
orca literally says the same line go
back to your shadows
does anybody know what character that is
absolutely interesting and he stayed
dead forever yeah right because once
gandalf died that [ __ ] was
always done so anybody like watching
like i can't
like there's a guy who was just like
you're a [ __ ] like
a terrible storyteller because you
killed off orco forever and i'm like
forever bro have you ever seen one of
these [ __ ] things yeah what do you
like about it
oh my god i just and even within the
first five episodes someone dies
two people [ __ ] die yeah they come
back even the tree guy [ __ ] comes
back like
so at that point you're like are you
[ __ ] serious are you just denying
reality like i i saw you think here even
better do you think mattel i'd walk in i
was like you know what i want to do
kill orco yeah done
money money money yeah do you know what
they would do there's the door silent
bill
you know like and again people are like
oh man this is the [ __ ] tila show and
stuff
like yes as i said from the beginning
tila plays a very prominent part in
stuff and if you follow closely and read
between the lines you see where we're
going with it we're continuing the
classic story that they began years ago
episode six of the [ __ ] show is
tila's quest if i can drop
some [ __ ] receipts here of original
information
correct yeah it's called tila's quest
what happens in that episode written by
paul
what happened six out of [ __ ] 200 i
mean they made so many episodes of that
show within two years right
six front loaded the very beginning of
the thing is about
tila's backstory and her
destiny which is she is adopted amanda
arms is not her biological
you know i'm talking about i'm talking
about a thing that happens
i'm just saying uh but in any way what
he's saying and what he's over
saying and getting us some [ __ ]
trouble you're not pulling this out of
your ass that's been there for four
years
is that like we're not we didn't [ __ ]
create anything new one of the things
that we did from the very beginning
let's find the most interesting
storyline in this storyline was
interesting it was there the tied into
the storyline
we wanted to do
it's annoying as your [ __ ] character
um
what we were trying to do of course was
the key to telling an extended he-man
story we were telling
he-man episodics like they did with
he-man in the masters universe
you know everything just resets at the
end of the episode obviously we're
telling one long episode that's chopped
into story
um chopped into into chapters the key to
the story is
basically it's keep away you have to
keep away
with the sword like whoever gets the
[ __ ] sword becomes the master of the
universe
so in order to make an interesting story
the first thing you do is take the most
powerful man in the universe
and try to [ __ ] keep the sword away
from him how we do it in episode one
is he gives his [ __ ] life he
sacrifices his life now
you know i've been accused of lying for
saying that uh that i'm like he man does
no st
stepping aside i if he if he man giving
his life for the entire universe is
stepping
aside then tony stark stepped aside
jesus christ stepped aside like it's a
messianic moment and if you follow like
you know
classic literature the heroes are like
bless you
it's where the hero has to go eventually
you have to sacrifice your life
for some greater cause than yourself no
greater [ __ ]
uh sacrifice than that so with us we
were like okay
like we don't have the benefit of just
resetting
every episode we're telling one long
episode and whatnot
and let's try to tell a story about what
happens when
people who you know thought they knew
things were
find out they were [ __ ] lied to while
we're playing keep away of the sword
yeah
so the first five that everybody could
see like
to me maybe because i know the back five
and i'm in the back five like the first
five i haven't dealt with in months
they've been done and sitting there
we're still dealing with back five right
now and stuff
but the point of the first five of
course is to set up the next five it's
an arctic story that goes like this
and um there's like when when folks are
are going like oh man like you
[ __ ] what's the word the emasculated
um he-man i'm like by making him
sacrifice himself to save
all the eternia like that's that's not
sidelining or he's not stepping aside
that's
pretty that's heroic like that's the
point of a hero instead
right he didn't go there too hot for me
where's the exit you know it's like
i i also feel like if i mean to come to
your defense
the the thing that frustrates me so much
about this like
lie thing right yeah is that
people are coming up knocking on your
door and saying like
is it true that this happens in episode
four [ __ ]
nine months before the show comes out
well how are you supposed to answer that
question you want people to watch the
thing in real time you want to see the
story unfold you don't want to preload
those expectations
you got to get tricky with your words to
be able to to
weave around these traffic cones i
didn't think i was tricky with the words
i literally said
tila does no stepping stones i think you
were yeah she has a friend who's a girl
but not a girlfriend
she does not wield this sort of power
i'll just tell you right now man [ __ ]
this is another spoiler and netflix is
gonna be like shut your [ __ ] mouth
but she never wields the sword ever in
any of the episodes
so everything i said was like god's
honest [ __ ] truth
and a bunch of people like you better
apologize for lying i'm like i didn't
lie
all of those things are [ __ ]
factually true but it's like rolling up
to george lucas and going like why
haven't you acknowledged
that darth vader is luke's father and
he's like it's 1975. slow your roll i
haven't shot the first one yet
wait your turn i feel look i you know
the
folks have uh you know uh have been
saying you apologize to
clownfish clownfish was the the
operation that
uh uh website and video show and stuff
whatever it is the
and i'm not dismissing it i have to be
so [ __ ] careful because anything i
say that like you're attacking clownfish
and i'm like not at all
i've always been very [ __ ] kind to
clownfish well regardless
um clownfish people are saying you you
lied to
clownfish you gotta apologize and i
honestly [ __ ] believe
with my heart i put my child's life on
it none of those things i said are
[ __ ] lies they're all factual and
[ __ ]
um i will uh apologize for
like leaning into it and and
tweeting and then hitting it again
tweeting again later on
simply to obfuscate from what i felt
like was the thing i didn't want anyone
to know
same day the clownfish's tweet goes up
there's some other tweet
that said something to the effect and
again we're spoiling the show so
hopefully everyone's seen it
that said something to the effect of i
hear
they kill adam in episode one
so right then and there i'm like jesus
christ we're like [ __ ] months away
from this thing coming out if this out
it's like oh man that's gonna suck
and not because i'm like oh they'll all
hate me and [ __ ] for emasculating he-man
more because like i just didn't want to
spoil what was a cool thing not only
that i mean they're so in the spoilers
oh yes yes please please please yes
while i was sitting there going like oh
[ __ ] they're gonna start talking about
this
over here is a conversation that i can
address
like that's like where they're like hey
man i hear tila i hear you man steps
aside tila
you know has a girl all the things i
said so i was like i can answer this
and maybe take attention away from this
over here and mercifully that never got
louder yeah like nobody ever knew so
that when the first episode played for
people
they were surprised yeah i i hope i mean
some
far too surprised and very vocal about
it on twitter
um which like again i understand like
i'm a fan of things i i don't get that
vocal if somebody does a thing that i
don't care for and stuff like that
um like i you know i love twin peaks i
didn't care for the
showtime sequel years later but you
didn't see me on the net going what the
[ __ ] david lynch you ruined my childhood
and [ __ ] like that it's just like
generally for me
you'll never hear about the [ __ ] that i
don't like that's kind of the way like i
operate and stuff
but as a fan of things i understand what
people like it's not what i [ __ ]
wanted it to be
and stuff and that's absolutely fair i'm
i'm not
i'm a man of peace i don't like fighting
with [ __ ] people it so
irritates me that this is going on that
there is a contingency of people and
mind you like we're talking about it
like it's everything and stuff
it's it's a very vocal contingency that
i pointed out like
at one point i talked to my netflix
friends and i was like i mean did you
see this like are we in trouble
and they were very kind and this is not
meant to mock anybody but they were like
kevin do you think we decide to
uh pick up other seasons of shows based
on the audience rating at rotten
tomatoes
and i was like you don't and they're
like [ __ ] no and um
so at that point like it didn't matter
and then
i mean this like is
here i'm like i don't this ain't me
being smarmy i know someone's gonna
paint it otherwise and [ __ ] like that
this is just me being honest if you
don't like something kids
don't [ __ ] talk about it yeah because
when you draw attention to it somebody
else goes what's that
so there was an article that went up few
articles the one i saw was on up rocks
and there's a few other sites
that talked about how we were review
bombed which is a practice where a bunch
of people like [ __ ]
hit a project hard with reviews i am
i've retweeted and people like
hey man [ __ ] you only got bad reviews
because it sucks it's not review bombing
and [ __ ] these aren't bots these are
real [ __ ] people
eat my butthole yes i i like i get it
yeah i'll happily eat your butthole i
i was not saying all you had to do was
ask kindly
totally i'm right there
but this was this was you know like i
i all that butthole talk really
distracted sorry
um
um what were we talking about uh the
review behind putting attention on a
thing you don't like yes
streisand effect they they it destroys
that effect yeah absolutely
they um there's an article articles
talking about this review bombing i have
nothing to do with the articles i
retweeted the one article and i said
i'm like oh at least we're in good
company they did this to the boys and
captain marvel
many people were very quick to point out
they only did this to the boys because
they were putting out one episode a week
and captain marvel like why would you
compare yourself to that if those are
your two
you know [ __ ] rocks you're standing
on your [ __ ] [ __ ] like that so you
know when people hate a thing they
[ __ ] find a way to defeat you on
every point and every turn
and so um i didn't they were acting like
i said that we'd been review bomb i was
literally [ __ ] quoting an article
that was up
um that review bombing thing
like i it was so weird because i'd i'd
been a witness to it from the outside
in other occasions i remember when that
happened the boys and i was like how
strange
and when it happened to captain marvel
you know never did i thought
we'd be at the epicenter of it but there
we were and stuff
and so naturally i was like oh my god
what does this mean like
is it going to bum anybody out or we
going to [ __ ] be in trouble
and um the folks upstairs
like put it on front street and this is
not me being a dick man this is just me
kind of explaining like how
counterproductive it is to go all
in against something you hate um their
reaction was like kevin
this is amazing for the show
and i was like yeah but all these people
are mad they were like yes it looks like
about
five to ten thousand people have written
nasty things
and they were like but we have 210
million subscribers
and i was like oh so mathematically
we're safe they're like safe as kittens
so so like it's you can do it and i'm
trying to stifle anybody's freaking
speech absolutely go ahead and stuff
but it's it's it won't do what you think
it's gonna do yeah i i
too like them was like oh my god this is
a bad thing and
they were intending to do a bad thing
and i'm not saying it's a nefarious plot
or
bots and [ __ ] but all the people like
this little suspect that are
you know what is it called [ __ ]
certified fresh
and then our audience rating is like in
the toilet right
but and so just so everyone doesn't say
like he thinks it's a [ __ ] conspiracy
i'm not saying that that's what i read i
don't know what to think at this point
[ __ ] like that but i do know this much
based on what i was told by the people
that like pay my salary
that doesn't matter to them like they
they literally don't care somebody
didn't send me tweets where like i was
on
comic book men one season and i was like
yeah i was a big he-man fan and [ __ ]
like that
and they're like aha like as if netflix
was gonna be like kevin you should have
told us
there's the door you know like that [ __ ]
doesn't like matter to anybody
who writes a [ __ ] check or something
like that so you can you can
like rumble young man rumble by all
means i was 20 once and i [ __ ] hated
things as well
um so and and pop off as as much as you
like come with me on twitter
my twitter stream is like honestly but
95
love fest of people who are like this is
amazing involving very complimentary
i thank all those people and then five
percent of you ruined my childhood
you're a cuck
um [ __ ] a lot of very drunk joy and
then some people who aren't even
derogatory who just write
long tweets about how i ruined it and
stuff like that
long thoughtful tweets um so you know in
that stream
it's still positive like it's
like i'm like other than
you know the me going like oh my god
this up
rocks article and and reaching out to
the powers that be
the moment that they were like oh what
are you doing like
don't worry about it suddenly i got to
kick back and like literally enjoy
what's going on man we worked real hard
you were sweating bullets this morning
when i showed up at the stash
and i said like look i'm reading [ __ ]
everything against my
therapist's suggestion
[Laughter]
that's what i gotta get somebody in my
life was like why are you reading this
that's also not true my therapist
retired years ago which is why i'm
reading the comments
um but but i i said like look man i'm
reading all of it and
most of it is so positive and the people
who are positive
are positive for the exact reasons we
hope and then we got to spend the day
today
actually you know after a pandemic
coming face to face with people and
having them really say what they
have the revelation celebration of this
plug plug plug
um but that that stuff plug something
that's sold out
i can plug things no because people
listening to this in the future they've
invented time travel and they're like
i'll go back go get a ticket
can you imagine that would mean we might
have time travelers in this audience
that will yeah that would be cool um
anybody here kill
baby hitler i'll say
oh my man was like congrats
uh thank you mazel um
i'm jewish i'm jewish i'm jewish i can
make the joke i can make the joke
um the thing i was gonna say this is a
once again
people allowed to dislike the thing
allowed to criticize it yeah yeah
absolutely right this is the thing that
bums me out
is a lot of the sentiment i have seen
the negative sentiment comes with this
tinge of like
why did you waste your time doing this
or putting this in the show real fans
don't care about that
right and inevitably a lot of that stuff
will circle back to
uh the presence of female characters or
people of color or certain subjects
themes or this or that there were
certain hot buttons for for a lot of
people
of course is one people furious about
haircuts yeah and they're like oh man
that's like ripped off i was like yeah
it was ripped up
we stole it from uh kyler lee on
supergirl yeah she did that through her
hair one year i was like that looks
wicked let's do this yeah she looks
awesome
um but but yes it it it is always framed
with this like that's not what the real
fans care about why
are you doing this stuff that's going to
go wasted on real fans and the thing i i
really
don't like and i say this as
non-antagonistically as possible
is uh fans defining which fans
count other fans count because you're
looking at something like motu that's 40
years
old has had all these different things i
was saying to you earlier today
the you know the first stuff written for
motu
was the mini comics that came with the
figures because they didn't have a show
on the air yet
and when the show comes out they negate
a lot of the stuff in the mini comics
and you see fans online who go once they
started the cartoon show the thing was
over for me
right i was out then they ruined the
character i liked him better when he was
a barbarian he went met a green lady she
gave him a harness
right that was for me that is the mini
comment right that's the last time
he-man was good for me and then there
are people who go it ends when filmation
ends i i only like the 2000 expert i
like the comics i like this i like that
right people like it for different
reasons and different people like it for
different reasons very true and these
people
and some people there are a lot of
people who seem mad at us
who were big fans of the mike young
production 2002 version like you [ __ ]
that up and i'm like but we didn't
we couldn't even touch that that wasn't
allowed right right allowable for us to
play with and stuff so we didn't
[ __ ] that up and then you realize that's
their
masterpiece of the universe right and
that's no more or less
valid right and the other part of it is
some of the people who are not just fans
of this thing but like
pillars of the community people who are
hosting podcasts and doing fan art and
doing cosplay and writing the bios on
the back of the action figures
are people who are part of the
communities that you're saying
don't matter and don't count as real
fans not to mention the people who work
on these things themselves
built the building blocks of the things
you're loving in the first place have
played these roles have written these
parts have done this animation
what have you it's a big bummer when i
see people going like
why are you trying to please them
they're not real fans who are you to say
you're a real fan i'm not going to tell
you you're not a real fan just because
you're being a dick to these other fans
that's your choice you're a real fan
it's always been fandom though as far
back as i can recall it's a bunch of
people dressed like stormtroopers going
look at those [ __ ] jerks dressed like
vulcans
great um but you know it's tribal i've
always gotten that and going into this i
mean i'll be honest with you like i
i've always felt like oh my god everyone
will love this like it's so
sweet and and you know it's not even me
taking credit going i'm a great writer i
had a lot of help and also
even the [ __ ] i did by myself was
predicated on [ __ ] other people did
years and years ago so there was very
little creativity involved there was
very much
taking all the assets and all the
backstory mythology and shaping
something fairly new and stuff
so like in in doing that you know
i i i had a lot of help the powerhouse
animation kids
our directors pat and adam writers in
and of themselves and how much they
added to the show
and whatnot so this ain't just me going
like i like what i do so i thought
everyone else would
but i felt like for the first time in my
career
like i made something that more than
kevin smith fans would enjoy
and i was like wow and it works and like
i think it's going to play
and it's doing that um for a lot of
people but some people it's
it's not doing that but you know i
in my child's heart i hope that it would
have blanketed everybody i hope that
would have made people
happy like i i've never once tried to be
[ __ ] divisive in my career it's like
a running joke in my [ __ ] crowd but
doing a [ __ ]
27 years and then i wind up doing [ __ ]
that like
makes people mad and it's not my
intention there's some people that are
provocaters
who like go out of their way to [ __ ]
piss the audience off and stuff like
that
i'm so not that guy man i'm just like
[ __ ]
like i'm a stoner i'm like i don't want
a [ __ ] hassle and [ __ ]
and my whole career like [ __ ] will
happen where it's you know like
[ __ ] chasing amy some people got mad
dogma yeah a lot of [ __ ] people got
mad
and [ __ ] with the death threats yeah um
jersey girl oddly enough a lot of
[ __ ] people got mad
[ __ ] yoga hoes like periodically mall
rats even some people got mad
people that loved clerks were like [ __ ]
this mall red it's maybe we put you
where you are and this is what you make
[ __ ] that so there's
no matter what you intend like and i
have the purest intentions for masters
of the universe
like you'll wind up hitting people who
are like you suck
but this is one of those moments that
links up with the other
big you suck moments in my my career now
some of those moments turned out later
on i didn't suck so hard like small rats
they came after me are going this sucks
particularly the critics
sequel sequel exactly right 10 years
later
the audience found it and fell in love
with it and [ __ ] like that
um so i know i've been doing this long
enough to know like this will
absolutely pass i know there's some
people that i have some people
sent screenshots of i've canceled my
netflix uh subscription and [ __ ] like
that
it's like good luck watching bridgerton
now you're only hurting yourself
what are you going to talk about around
the office come on you're playing
yourself
um the uh you know it's
there's there's five more to to go
hopefully when they see the
people that see them people that enjoy
it will enjoy it even more
um and then hopefully the people who are
like this isn't what i wanted
will be like now this is what i'm
[ __ ] talking about but there will
always be i feel like a contingency of
people that are like no this is not it
for me yeah so i've gotten like the
single best reviews of my career i got a
certified
[ __ ] fresh rating on rotten tomatoes
that never happens for any kevin smith's
[ __ ] whatsoever
but oddly enough if you look over at the
audience score it's like the worst of
my career and stuff so you know and one
neither truly tells the story
i guess yeah the truth is somewhere in
between but
uh i know it's being watched a lot so
we'll see what happens there it's
exciting
i just want to put out there that you
know there's a 130
other episodes of masters of the
universe that people can watch if they
don't like your five
you didn't go and take their dvds away i
went through this
as a big star wars fan when they disney
erased the expanded universe and i was
like
my my timothy's on book is still on the
shelf i can go read it they didn't come
here and take it
you know so like i'm sure in those 130
episodes there were some episodes
uh that people didn't like and you just
don't re-watch them
you know there's a ton of he-man out
there and that's awesome
as well like if you know it's like
anything else like this is not mine i
didn't create it
if you don't like this iteration of
masters of the universe
just wait five minutes yeah like another
one's coming down the back there's
literally another show coming uh
he-man in the masters universe it's
called and it's cg version of the show
um beautiful as hell and i think when
we're over that show starts
but even just regardless of that
someone else is going to pick this up in
the next five years
and make it theirs and stuff and they
might make it the version uh that you're
you're hoping for if you really hate the
[ __ ] out of this
um but the people that are loving the
[ __ ] out of this
they're you know they're not wrong you
know just like i'm not saying you people
who don't like it are wrong
the people that like it aren't wrong
either and [ __ ] are they loving it man
i've i've seen
so many moving [ __ ] tweets lots of
tweets of kids
like when they were kids in the 80s with
their castle grey skulls and their
figures and stuff like that
people who have been lifelong fans who
were just like this is everything that i
ever wanted to be
blah blah blah posted a photo of his
little daughter like a toddler standing
from the screen holding up the sword
you know that's awesome uh rules i just
i just want to butt in
uh jc and just say uh
don't encourage them to watch the other
140 episodes because we don't get
residuals off of that
so we can that was another orc
but watch these five like multiple times
um by all reports that's what's
happening yeah it's it's
look i i mean you know i i uh
a couple of times have foolishly waded
in and poked the bear a little bit and
just said like
what is your problem with this on
twitter right and see i don't even do
that
i know i shouldn't i should once again
my therapist is retired it's not my
fault
i really it's hard to find a new one but
um
i'm not i'm not poking confrontation i'm
really trying to like figure like what's
your problem with this because i'm i'm
like
i am a genuine fan i almost said real
fan after going on my uh anti
uh who is a real fan right right but i'm
a genuine fan of this stuff
and i'll sort of say like i think yeah
this and that whatever
and they go well of course you're paid
to defend it and i go no i'm paid to say
the words and then they can't tell me
what the [ __ ] to say after that right
they're not sending me on this press
store i'm not mark hamill i'm not gonna
get the views up you're asking me to do
this because i was local or i was
cheaper to bring me over here
but but the point is it's true it's true
but also more importantly than that i
had such a
blast on the george lucas talk show well
yes it was like i'm not even sure i'm
not blowing it off because he's here it
was
absolutely one of my favorite things i
did last year
it was so [ __ ] fun who's the other
who plays george lucas connor ratliff
who for my money is the funniest person
in new york city and he's been doing
this
for years he interviews real celebrities
as
george lucas and in character as george
lucas and i'm sort of his
ed mcmahon as watto the uh
the address is like i got the whole
thing yeah um
and kevin was amazing if you want to
look for it on youtube it's up there
but um i i you know what i want to say
these people is like
i've been in stuff that [ __ ] sucks
right like i'm i
most of my careers garbage is diarrhea
right trying to pay them that's why we
made a marco
yeah no but the the point is like when
i'm in a thing that sucks i just don't
say anything
you know i'm not going out there and
promoting it no one's paying me to
promote this
you know and and even doubly so because
i was a fan of this beforehand
if i fought this hard to get the power
organ i had this fear like oh my god i
want this so badly
and then i go wait a second what these
suck like what if these scripts are
garbage and i'm the guy
who made orko a loser right uh and i
read them and i went i love these i
don't know what people are gonna think
of them but for me as a fan this is like
the thing i've always wanted to see
and so i'm out there defending it
genuinely you can believe that or not
but i will just say i've said [ __ ] i
shouldn't have said before
about things that we're involved in i'm
i'm not known for being a very strategic
person in that sense right uh to the
detriment of my own career
um but but this is a thing i genuinely
love and i watched it last night you
know i finally
got to see the whole thing and it's
changed god this is like
in my mind's eye the show i've always
wanted to see and excite i know
everything that's going to happen i'm
still excited when you
died did you get emotional yeah yeah
yeah and i'll say this i mean this is
what i love about animation
every time i've been in something on
camera i'm watching it i'm not getting
emotions
does my nose really look like that you
know
but this i'm like man orca is a good
actor look at his eyes here and i'm like
yeah i can't take any credit for that
i'm not
distracted and it's just the writing it
really is it's it's the writing and the
animation you know i'm plugging my ears
and not listening to what i'm saying but
like
it really does it hits me i was watching
it knowing everything that was going to
happen
and every beat played for me as it it
should you know
and then the weird magic of like
watching oh my god this evil linorco
dynamic is so cool and i'm not thinking
about the fact that i'm that
guy because it's a thousand other people
have touched it along the way i've drawn
it and she's done her
dialogue and all of you have taken your
pass on every line and all this sort of
stuff
all the powerhouse animation kids in
austin loved you
a because your performance is wonderful
but b
because orco has no mouth well yeah
there's no sync right here you brought
me in for some last minute
uh redux because you're like this is the
one character we can add new dialogue
for it doesn't cost us a goddamn scent
you gotta
change his lips yeah normally when you
like you know if you're far along in the
process and you're like wait we want to
change something
you know it's like [ __ ] turning a
ship because you've gotta go reanimate
that sequence so the lip flap
syncs up and stuff um so there were a
few
times uh we did that there's a line in
the in episode 10
from uh man at arms that we changed only
like
four weeks ago and had to match up what
we were doing because they were locked
so we couldn't like just
have them reanimate that piece so
episode uh
four when they go to subternia
um you know it used to open with them
walking around it was quiet and it was
just atmospheric and stuff like that
i'm used to people telling me like take
out the dialogue there's too much
dialogue
so i didn't put any dialogue in and then
the netflix note we got back after we
saw the first animated pass
was like let's let's give some let's put
some dialogue in this section
so you know the powerhouse kids were
like oh my god we're gonna have to
reanimate and stuff and i was like well
i can write it for orco
and if orco does it there's no lip flap
and they're like thank you
so the poem that he said the trolling
nursery
right right right i think one of the
last things you did yeah
yeah can i let me say something to to
compliment
you uh
when we went in for the first recordings
marathon we were doing first pass
at least the first four episodes i think
all at once
and there was the spell at the beginning
the first episode where he puts cringer
in the bubble
and you went like the spells are we
should have written more spells and this
man came up with like
five spells off the dome and those
things have to rhyme
i know but they're real simple baby i
don't know i'm easily impressed like i
was eminem in the room
and [ __ ] i was like bubble trouble there
you go
i can fill in the blanks i mean my
mediocre impression of you is you go
okay kids pencils out every time you had
a new line you go pencils out
well we're trying to beat the line when
we're recording this is your last bite
at the apple right
like scripts are great but you're like
oh like that line works but what if we
did this
so you're like hey man let's throw that
out i drive this and then sometimes you
hear a line you're just like that didn't
work it's not because the actor just
line kind of lays there and stuff
so at that moment be like all right kids
pencils out let's beat this line
um no but yes you know as an actor
uh with on camera stuff the worst worst
part of the job i would argue
even ahead of waking up early is um
uh adr yeah where they're trying to fix
dialogue but it's
it's you it's the image it's done and
then you have to sync it to a picture
they play it on right you're in front of
you and you have to say it along with
the old version of yourself
and try to make it sink and sometimes
it's like oh there was a car passing by
we missed that word you're watching your
face
why am i pronouncing that weird and
trying to match it so it sounds natural
and not like a
you know a poorly dubbed martial arts
movie or whatever
but the other part of it is sometimes
they're going like we didn't get this
line we got to fit it in here
you could fit it in a where there's no
i'm on screen for two seconds i'm
clearly saying a different word i'm
saying [ __ ]
you want me to say thank you you know
it's not gonna work
and with orco it's like his eyes are
looking to the left so can you just say
it like his eyes are looking to the left
he's like yeah that's easy
yeah yeah that's an easy directional
performance right
that's all we just got the scarf yeah um
it was magical work sir and uh such a
pleasure
again like i ain't i won't spoil
anything for anybody but
um i suspect griffin will be back
when we put up the next five because
we'll have some things to talk about at
that point
um that being said that was a [ __ ] ton
of content kids give it up for griffin
newman that was amazing
um hold the bottom oh yes the bottom
bottom the bottom there we go
everybody leaves here tonight gonna walk
away with one of these amazing posters
man this is the final poster for the
show it's got a
[ __ ] ton of characters all of which show
up in our show
so when you guys head out tonight
they'll give you one of those all rolled
up to take with you
um the artist's name escapes me but i i
don't want to ever
ever like leave an artist uncredited
um so let me just scroll down on my
twitter while you're scrolling can i can
i say something to this audience uh
absolutely this was my first time doing
anything in front of a crowd uh
where the societal expectations that
you're supposed to pay attention to me
also known as
a show uh who are you roboto um
but uh in like uh 20 months or whatever
it's been it's so nice to be in front of
a crowd again
i'm a stupid comedy dude i miss
being in basements and dang places and
you do web shows and things like that
and it's really not the same
this is the juice and that having been
said i you know i really appreciate you
folks being
so great and so cooperative and wearing
masks and doing the dorky thing and all
that sort of [ __ ] but i gotta ask a
favor of all of you which is i need to
be
so bad please it's it's here's the weird
thing it's right
no i'm aware that's why i'm bringing it
up because like i'm gonna ride out
as you finish up but then let me go just
please let me go i'm gonna run i'll be
super quick we're not even done we're
about halfway through the show
so you can totally go pee just know that
we're all gonna listen cool i'm gonna do
it
make it loud um the poster is by nathan
berch um it's gorgeous such a gorgeous
poster
uh the good folks at netflix sent that
over for us we were giving them out at
revelation celebration while uh
griffin's uh
avoiding the little orco uh
anybody have a motu question of course
we'll do our q a
uh later on but does anybody have a
question about revelation
uh that i can answer for you right here
while we're stalling for time
castle keeper ernie o'donnell there's a
hand right there
ready to bring a mic right to you that's
service give it up for castle keeper
ernie o'donnell you gentlemen
thank you um i'm always curious
especially since you know a few weeks
ago we found out some things batman
doesn't do
um when you were in kind of the planning
[ __ ] process yes he does okay awesome
yeah no but was there anything maybe
because you were working with a lot of
other big fans and you know we know
you're a fan
maybe somebody stepped in and said hey
that's not what they would do
yeah absolutely why i never
like worried about like oh people are
gonna hate the show
because my bosses were two
of the biggest masters of the universe
fans on the planet so
over at uh mattel television the guy
that hired me rob david
he's not just a suit at mattel he has
been writing
masters of the universe comic books for
dc for the last like two years attorney
of warship like that
so he's forgotten more about motu than
most will ever know
and on the other side we had the
aforementioned ted biaselly
uh anime ted on instagram if you will
who
like we're living in his dream the old
reason this [ __ ] show exists
is because of teddy i've told the story
many times i'll tell it one more time
when i met him
to pitch the show and he was like you
know what that's great let's do that and
i got hired
he told me he was like when i was a kid
i watched every episode of this show and
i [ __ ] was terrified
that skeletor was gonna kill he-man
every time he's like then i got like
five years older and i realized that was
never going to happen all i'm asking you
to do
is make the version of the show that i
thought i was watching when i was a kid
i just want to believe there are stakes
i want to believe that like you know
people can get killed in the show and
stuff
so we had a moment where i wrote the
how the project was is like i came up
with an outline and then we brought in
the writers and then the outline got
better and [ __ ] because they've almost
thrown in stuff it's like
making of soup where everybody brings
ingredients and [ __ ]
but um in my pilot inland's barely pile
in the first episode
there's a moment where uh you know a
very opening
uh he-man or what looks like you man and
uh you know a couple of reprobates that
he's bringing to
castle grayskull uh the sorceress flies
out of the eye of graceful in
zore form and then met them
like on the grounds and teddy
called me and he was just like that
would never happen
and i was like i don't know how to tell
you this teddy but none of this [ __ ]
would ever happen you got to be more
specific and he was just like well
she can't leave the castle like she
can't leave grace goal
so she can she can fly out
in bird form as azure but like if she's
going to
maintain the form of the saucers she has
to be connected to grayskull
he's like so you can put her on the on
the jaw bridge
but she can't step off the jaw bridge
little things like that make the
difference you know so that
true fans and i'm not saying true fans
as opposed to people who are mad they're
true fans as well
um but true fans would have caught that
right away
and that's like the opening minutes of
our series and might have been like well
this [ __ ] don't know what they're
doing
and [ __ ] like that so we we had
cilla and charybdis like around us at
both times and they didn't smash us and
destroy us
they would come in and [ __ ] like mold
us make it better
because they knew everything so we
couldn't
step off the path like i was literally
never afraid
of pissing off the fan base at all
because of those two cats because i'm
like jesus they're not gonna let me go
wrong like
it's rob's job to make sure that we sell
a bunch of [ __ ] toys so like
naturally they didn't want to step off
the path they wanted to make sure that
like
this thing worked in a way for everybody
and teddy too was like i want to do more
of this like you know he wants to do
many seasons not like let's do it once
he's got a vision and [ __ ] like that
so you know and like i'm i'm not
i'm trying how much can i like i'm
before i um
there's gonna be more like that's all
i'm saying uh for now and stuff
but um we i i never felt
like oh my god we'll we'll [ __ ] this up
somehow because of those guys
that was the moment that leaps to mind
though right away and it echoes
throughout the entire show
second half of the show the idea of the
saucers not being able to leave grey
skull is a huge [ __ ] plot point
and so in saying that you know i was
like oh [ __ ] is that real i was like all
right and suddenly it made the whole
[ __ ] show better god bless you
and help me redevelop like the back five
so yeah it did happen and i'm i'm not
like one of the like this isn't
me making a jay in silent bob movie for
example like as we announced earlier
this week we're making [ __ ] clerks 3.
when you guys aren't sitting here this
is the production offices for clerks 3.
we did our production meeting in here
we're gonna do our script meet uh
reading next week right in this room and
[ __ ] like that
so like i'm making my thing and
you know i'm open to people being like
oh you should try this or would you
think of this or blah blah blah
but if anyone was ever like oh randall
wouldn't do this i was like the [ __ ] you
say
because that shit's mine you know i can
[ __ ] i dictate exactly what the
musketeer characters do and don't say
master the universe is not my property
but i'm stretching the imagination i'm
literally
playing with somebody else's toys so i
could never sit there and be like
well what the [ __ ] i need her to be
outside the castle for my scene to work
and [ __ ] like i was always interested in
towing the line because
like ironically i never wanted any true
fan
to have an upsetting experience i wanted
them to feel like oh my god my toys are
exactly where i left them
and i'm i'm still going to play with
them even though i'm this age
so yes there were definitely moments and
but they weren't moments of like you
can't do this like
i didn't go for anything um
kevin smith you know what i'm saying
like i wasn't like let's [ __ ] put in
somebody's got to say 69 although there
is a fisto joke i'll be honest with you
what what if they smoke moss man yes
yeah
that's a [ __ ] where were you in the
room
the good [ __ ] material you ain't just
a funny guy you're a writer my friend
um so yes uh hopefully that answers the
question
um all right griffin's back he's done
taking a leak and stuff any questions
about the leak i'm happy to answer
i'm pretty well it's the fourth seltzer
that gets you
you know that's really that's the one
that's the point did you shake or tap
do a little bit of both oh a little
serpent terp ladies and gentlemen
griffin newman um okay news
um things happen and i asked nate
normally of course mark who we miss and
love
mark is spending as we talked about last
week uh this weekend with his mom is in
town so that's why he's not doing the
show luckily griffin's here so bam we
get to do a show
normally mark like digs up the news
right he's always the guy make a big
deal about it and [ __ ] like that
so oh my god this is
i mean this is name droppy but bobby
moynihan just dropped me a text and goes
hey man it's bobby moynihan
just wanted to say fantastic job with
masters truly enjoyed hope all as well
it's [ __ ] nice what a sweet looking
look i don't name jeff by moynihan
texted me this morning so
i maybe got the bob in one hand text a
little bit earlier he texted you as well
yeah he's big orc really i i know him
primarily from doing uh george lucas
talk show and having mutual comedy
friends but uh he
he was like man i love orco so much i'm
so excited to see what you guys do
and then his next question was is
someone else playing ram man because i
want
ram man is that uh
it's been cast i mean
i gotta get him in something i love him
um okay
i asked nate the dark nate uh returns
gonzales who does all our show art the
art that's behind us
i say man can you pull some news stories
from me like mark did and
mark does and he goes i would be honored
um however he just wrote uh before we
get into the news stories please thank
griffin
and mark for writing this specific
moment for his performance
especially the moment where he's talking
to evil in
on the boat about forgetting all of his
adventures memory loss is a less talked
about
symptom of deep depression and i doubt i
was the only person who related to that
monologue beautiful moment come on bro
that's correct but in fact the person he
talks about memories to is andra so
point negated compliment
rejected you're not a real fan um
no i definitely i i related to that uh
hard
it's a really sweet moment really
beautiful moment where he's so like you
know at that point like jesus
is this guy ever gonna cheer up like
he's always like i'm so old and sad
andre and then yeah when magic comes
back he gets all right
right there's also this kind of cool
meta thing to it where he's like look i
forget like i did 140 episodes of that
original show expect me remember all of
them it's true
um okay here are the news stories that
nate pulled first
uh normally mark bernard does it but
nate did it for us uh
nate gonzalez found us the news give it
up for nate gonzalez find us the news
okay here's the collection news he
picked out old is uh projected to beat
gi joe origin
snake eyes at the box office old is
projected to make just over 15 million
while snake eyes is looking like 14.2
did anybody see either of those flicks
yeah i saw old last night how was it
love it love it i
mean m knight was the first guy we did
on blank check and at this point i'm
just like i love you
beautiful black bastard you go for it
you know he goes so
goddamn hard yeah and i i loved him and
it went through the ark i think a lot of
us did where i was like where did this
guy go
you know and then
the village is when i got shaky yes but
but like and then it got shakier and
then i came back around and now i'm like
so it drips like now i've come all the
way back around to it i watched it 10
years later with fresh eyes
and it's at a certain point you know uh
you do your thing long enough and people
learn like that's their thing
why would i critique them for doing
their thing
don't ask this guy to be scorsese or
spielberg
judge him relative to m night shyamalan
movies and if you ask me as a fan of m
night shyamalan movies
old's a good [ __ ] my travel on movies
did you guys see it in the theater i saw
nether yeah i saw in the theater last
night
up in the city uh i did yeah he lives
in new york new york city or so wait did
were the theaters packed up there
wasn't crazy pack we went to a late
showing
uh it was funny though because it's like
you know we all got this weird culture
reputation with m knight is he a joke or
is he the master of horror
right half the time he asks us the palm
of the hands half the time i knew it i
saw it coming
and there's like a really groudi group
of teenagers in front of us
and for like half the movie they're like
suck my dick like to each other to the
screen
to the amc employees to everyone it's
like look i know we've all been cooped
up for 18 months but
ask nicely and
please would go a long way but then you
know they're like uh having fun with the
movie making fart sounds whatever
and then there are a couple scenes where
it's like pin drop silent
really and then you hear them catch
themselves and go like and it's like no
he got you
yeah he got you there he's got him
knighted yeah look it's a
goofy whack-a-doo movie this guy's told
us who he is at this point he likes to
swing for the fences you know
he wears his heart in his sleeve and he
has big ludicrous ideas
but i think there's some masterful
filmmaking in that movie it's divisive
like not everyone's gonna love it it's a
very particular taste you know it's
cilantro
or whatever it either hits your tongue
the right way or it doesn't
uh but i i deeply enjoyed it yeah you
just got a little taste of blank check
for free ladies and gentlemen give it up
for griffin yeah i know
we don't even record that episode until
tuesday yeah
oh you were doing rehearsal you're
testing it out i'm not sure
what else what else what else um he also
wrote pam greer is going to star in a
pet cemetery prequel
cool very nice i like anything that pam
greer is on walt disney's grandson loses
appeal and fight for 200 million dollar
inheritance
nice work if you can get it yeah really
yeah [ __ ] when you
wish upon a star you [ __ ] lose
you realize that by singing that on a
podcast you just added more money to the
pot
the grandson's fighting for right it's
oh my god it was counterproductive
what if i sing it out of key that's what
you have to do
when you wish
two things at once yeah uh shazam two
spoiler
oh an image of jim and hansu reportedly
from the set of shazam sequels surfaced
online he played the wizard
so i guess the wizard's back um
let's see what else uh an update from
neil blum
comp on district 10 i guess that's
moving forward
uh yes jordan peele's next movie
is simply called nope that's the name of
the movie and it stars daniel
kaluya kiki palmer and stephen young
uh this one was interesting man
christopher marcus and stephen mcfeely
marcus mcfeely
they wrote end game but they also wrote
all the captain americas we had them on
the show a long time ago they're
wonderful uh
they say that steve rogers and they
would know
they were the steve rogers screenwriters
lost his virginity
during the events of captain america
the first avenger in an interview with
yahoo entertainment marcus and mcfeely
offered up their thoughts on the topic
i think he loses his virginity mcfeely
said why do people think this guy is a
virgin
mcfeely suggested that rogers likely got
some action during his uso tour
that introduced him as captain america
and saw him promoting bonds
if you look like that and you're going
city to city you're signing autographs
for the likes of the ladies that he's
signing autographs for
i got to imagine that he lost his
virginity
like mcfeely explained i never thought
about
whether or not captain america got
[ __ ] no because we look like this we
go on tour
we're like yeah that doesn't happen but
he's right if you look like chris
you look like you're waiting for the
super soldier serum yourself i look like
it went wrong
kev you joke about that but i went to
see that with
with my buddy sam rogel and the second
you see shirtless steve rogers he turned
to me and he went
how did you not get this [ __ ] heart
as the body double
like he was like that should be chris
evans face on your disgusting body
and i i fired my agents i didn't i'm
sorry
they retired along with my therapist
um the dune new dune trailer did
everybody see the new dune trailer
it continues to look amazing um
this is the big news though michael b
jordan and his production company
outliers
uh outlier society are developing their
own
black superman project for hbo max
that centers on the val zod incarnation
of the character
collider has exclusively learned um
so it was talked about like a while ago
jj abrams i guess is making the black
super members
black coats but now there's a separate
black superman project which is based on
valzad yeah which is incontinuity and
stuff right
a lot of people when they announced the
clark kent black superman were like why
don't you just do valzad
right there apparently they are doing
bells yeah
look uh dc is going to take as many
bites at the apple as possible
you shouldn't complain about dc not
doing enough with their characters
because they'll they'll challenge you
and give you four times more than you
ask for
but then but this i mean it gets back to
superman like
can sustain a few incarnations yes
absolutely and they've kept them on the
bench for so long i know there are a lot
of fans that are like why not henry
cavill and stuff like that yeah i'm like
why not have any
cable either but right i would take nine
superman movies a year
like different adventures and different
incarnations that's what's what it is
for me about the the landscape we're in
right now and it gets i mean it gets
back to
you know fan response to motu or
whatever where it's like
you know we used to live in a culture
where someone [ __ ] up batman you're
like i guess
no more batman movies ever yeah you know
after batman and robin it was like all
right it's all over them never do that
again
right right and then now it's like if a
batman movie doesn't hit the public the
right way they're like
boy we got four more batman movies next
month let's hope one of them works
we're we're spoiled but it also means i
think
it is an opportunity to like be less
precious about all this because
you go to the comic book store there
might be four
different titles centered around batman
in any given month
right and they have different artists
and they have different continuities
maybe
the same country different writers
different takes different focuses
and you don't go this issue ruined
batman forever right you go okay i guess
i dropped that title for my pull list
and this is the one i like now until a
new creative team takes over
and i think i think that's the time
we're living in where it's like
yesterday
we've got four or five different
supermans right now we're big kids we
can take it we can keep track
and give it to him he seems passionate
about it yeah so
like you know i'd rather see it in the
hands of somebody that cares about he's
talking about
producing it's not just being like oh i
got cast he's like i'm
literally making this movie he's willing
it into existence well and you seems
like a big comic book fan
he does and obviously you've been very
vocal about your history of this but
working on on your super movie and all
these things
here's what i want to do here's what
john peters wants you to do and all this
sort of stuff and is the superman or
isn't it and all that
you know it's like i i read him in
interviews when people were
spreading rumors that he was going to do
the j.j abrams movie and he very early
on said like superman's got a lot of
weight in history and baggage i think
what would be more interesting to me as
a character that hasn't been on screen
before i'd like to have a fresh start
you know
and there is something to being like i'm
the first guy to play this dude
yeah as opposed to like i don't have to
right right
you know true marvel studios is thinking
about starting their own in-house
animation department kids
ep victoria alonso who i saw speak once
and boy oh boy was she good
and i was going in it was like for a
film school in los angeles
and somebody called me up and they're
like can you come speak to the kids and
whatnot it's like a graduation type
ceremony or something that's yeah
absolutely
and you know i was like oh my god i'm
going to go over huge with the [ __ ]
kids and that's silent bob and [ __ ] like
that i'm going to talk their language
and my curse is going to be [ __ ]
great
victoria alonso was one of the other
speakers and i was like
i'm going to be way better than her she
was magic
and she had on her side like i have a
string of super successful movies that
every one of these kids watch
i'm like hi kids i made clerks once you
know
she was great she was absolutely magical
i'd listen to her talk all the time here
she says
we're going to have our animation branch
and mini studio and there will be more
to come from that as well
alonzo said we're super excited about
animation
which is my first love have you seen the
trailer for what if yeah i think it
looks awesome and that's like i mean to
this point what we're just talking about
with the superman it's like
that's kind of the moment i've been
waiting for the last decade plus
of mcu is to get to that point where i
get so loose with it we're like this is
what would happen if like this ain't
canon
you get to play you get tough i mean i
loved uh anytime there was a what if
issue
and still do collected what if as a kid
yeah and i always
loved like sort of self-contained
mini-series when you had someone who
just got to do their thing it's not
going to have ripples on the rest of the
thing you get to just throw at a
concept it's i think that show looks rad
and really damp sport it's the marble
one the most excited and cool says it
has been proven for years but
the animation is [ __ ] scary it looks
awesome and [ __ ] jeffrey
right as well that's a lot in the bank
yes
yeah uh this piece of news says the rock
is done with the fast and furious
franchise
in a recent interview with the hollywood
reporter he was asked if he had seen
diesel's comments which basically boiled
their ongoing feud down to diesel
claiming his approach was a lot of
quote unquote tough love so the rock
said i laughed and i laughed hard i
think everyone had a laugh at that and
i'll leave it at that
and then i wished him well johnson said
before essentially confirming
that he would not be showing up in any
future fast and furious films
i wish them well on fast nine and i wish
them the best of luck on fast 10 fast 11
and the rest of the fast and furious
movies they do that will be without me
and i think that you don't turn your
back on family
even when family turns its back
on you and that is all i will say on the
subject
my allegiances are clear um
he didn't read that part of the script
apparently didn't communicate
yeah um he's got plenty to do man
[ __ ] you know he'll have
black lightning yes yes no black no
black adam black adams yes yes he'll
have black adam yeah but that guy's
pretty slow and pretty calm right yeah i
like my movies fast and furious
winston duke has confirmed that he is
indeed reprising his role
um as umbaku in uh marvel studios highly
anticipated sequel
black panther wakanda forever i thought
he was good he was really good in that
he's also good in the
in the um us movie as well he's a great
actor really
uh he's very very compelling i'm also
just like
you know the the the bozeman thing is
obviously
so deeply tragic um
but it puts this movie in such an odd
position
right yeah where like when you go
forward without your well it's to have a
movie that's like that
culturally seismic you know it's like
nominated for best picture it's one of
the highest grossing movies of all time
it really feels like it makes an impact
on
you know the planet yeah really i'm not
being glib here and then
in the universe for sure right and then
you don't get to make the obvious sequel
and who knows what that script would
have been
right by all accounts googler had a
script that was pretty ready to go
thinking that bozeman was going to be
able to um
pull it out you know and so it's it's
just
very interesting to be at a point right
now where you're like here's this huge
movie
obviously there's a sequel i have no
idea what it is
i have no idea what their angle is i
don't know what they do around it
any new piece of information i hear you
know
i tend to be a fan of sequels
that go lateral you know that take a
sort of offhand approach to what worked
in the first movie rather than trying to
top it you know
like for example if you take clerks and
move them from a convenience store fast
food restaurant that's lateral
yeah yeah um but yeah
i'm just very excited to see what that
in the next one we move it back to the
convenience store so that's backwards
what's still lateral though it's on the
same axis
uh yeah i'm excited to see what that
movie is i have no idea
which one uh uh oh clerks three who you
were talking about that
yeah black panther too uh me as well um
that was all the news that nate came up
with uh for us give it up for nate who
found you the news such a beautiful
[ __ ] so cool
um all right kids now we come to that
portion of the evening that everyone
waits for us where you get to be
part of the show we open up for q and a
before we do that let's check in with uh
jc
banff man bamf man come on oh welcome
back
um how was the chat um
like ride the chat pretty hard because
people get kind of vicious and stuff
like that to each other
i suspected this week there'd be a lot
of the enmity aims at me
so how are we doing it's amazing when
people like something how
much quieter they are than when they
don't like something
meaning a few people make a lot of noise
oh is that right yeah so what
i uh i pulled some some of my favorite
nice comments if you want to hear them
here
i'll take your paper 316
said uh top-notch work from griffin in
episodes to uh three and four
which i thought was cool episode one
though could you do some work should i
take another pack
uh iron ocean uh this isn't
about motu but said uh kev has found
someone in griffin who has
his love for talking as much as him i
bet they could have a conversation for
eight hours and not even realize it
at one point i was just like i could
probably leave right now he's got the
whole show
excellent job yes he's content generated
and uh
i like this one even though mark's not
here uh martine
hoker martinez said uh the downside of
mark and kevin working on a master's
of the universe project is we aren't
going to get the same salty and sweet
juxtaposition
of critic critical and celebratory
reviews
that's right mark's not gonna be like i
love it mark's not gonna be like it
could have been better
um it finally gets spared uh he seems to
love it
like he uh especially his episode
rightfully so
but he's said here on the show he's like
that's the first time i've ever seen
something i've written
be that close to the thing that it
became the final product i i
i feel that way too i i'm someone who
even this
the few things i've done that i have
been proud of before this moment
i watched my head it was a little bit
better
you know and this is the first time i'm
like this is better than i ever thought
it was going to be
and my expectations were unreasonably
high nice
yeah that's a good folks of powerhouse
animation that is such an amazing job
all right banff man you want to give us
an at-home uh or an online question
before we open it up to the good fold
yeah we um so uh goddammit russ
in chat said uh he knew the basics of
masters of the universe but was afraid
he'd be lost
he says nope they do a great job of
introducing it to a new fan
uh and then he goes on to ask his
question which
uh is apt because you said there's no
kevin smith
uh jokes really in masters of the
universe so he wants to know
which masters of the universe character
would be the best one to smoke with
hmm they previously mentioned
boss man yeah the one you smoke maybe
it's like who do you want to share moss
man with
well i think if you're going to be both
yeah i think if you're going to smoke
moss man you have to smoke moss man with
moss
you certainly offer yes you don't treat
him like a dealer where you're like i
just want my [ __ ] i don't want to talk
man like [ __ ]
you gotta like hey man can i have a
[ __ ] green one he gives you one and
then you're like so a million years old
huh
rocks you know [ __ ] like that i think
you'd uh i think mossman would be good
to talk to because he could provide you
uh with the substance that the
conversation would would be good over
i saw a few tweets this weekend uh
people impugning
uh my use of marijuana as they say that
have ruined
masters of the universe so we'll leave
weed right there
you same answer uh man at arms for me
has that energy of like the mysterious
roadie where you're like if i could get
this guy to cut loose i'd hear some
stories
you know the mysterious roadie no but
it's like he's professional if i can get
him to undo two buttons
i'm gonna get some scoops that's true so
that would be my focus
it's like what's the craziest party
you've ever
guarded at the palace and he's just like
i think one of the main characters is my
daughter
all right thank you for that banff man
now we need uh castle keeper ernie
o'donnell come on out here
and work the audience there he is give
it up to cassiopeia bernie o'donnell
ladies and gentlemen
ernie as you can see is wearing that
very [ __ ]
impressive smod castle shirt which if
you don't have you can pick up right
next door
quick stop uh that's right quick stop
convenience the home
dante um uh and also uh don't forget
jeff's kiss shirts ladies and gentlemen
they're still happening you can go uh
find that at jsonbob.com all right erin
i leave it up to you to pick
if you got a question throw your hands
in the air wave around like you just
don't care
ernie gonna pick you and then we'll get
to it look at him being judgey and [ __ ]
like that
he's like joaquin and gladiator he's
ready to [ __ ] put his thumb up or
down he picked one here we go ladies and
gentlemen what's your name sir
brian give it up for brian he's going
first
what did i do you for brian first time i
came back to pick up my jay
character like jay figure you're gonna
get you're taken care of for me so yeah
i said to jordan we were in uh jordan is
jay's wife
and like i said this is the product it's
a great way to get me back it's been 50
bucks so by the way
you'll definitely get it um but i saw it
when we were
uh in the other room that's uh the uh
where the
producers and the a.d work in the in our
green room during the week and stuff
but i was pointing out to her i was like
that figure up there you have to get jay
to sign
and she was like why don't you do it and
i was like why me and she's like i was
like why me you're his wife and she goes
you're his first wife so true i try he
didn't come tonight but i promise you it
will be
signed now here's the here's the better
deal ready because
i don't think we're going to do another
show while we're shooting the movie for
the cove
risk and stuff so i will take it to the
stash
and jay will sign it and it'll be there
to pick up for sure okay
deal was that the question no
go ahead but uh second of all the motu i
grew up with it
i watched all five episodes loved every
single one of them thank you so much
amazing work amazing work thanks you're
the haters
um but way back when clerks when all
this began
26 27 years ago
and you did all this did you and then
mall rats and then la and everything
else in between did you ever think it
was going to come full circle and you'd
be back in jersey
filming clerks 3. i honestly i never
thought i'd leave new jersey i thought i
would do everything here
a big point of pride at the beginning of
my career was i'm not going anywhere
like i'm going to live in red bank [ __ ]
everybody like because my job allows me
like to go places to do the job and in
in the beginning
i assumed i would make everything here
that was my dream and then because of
costs and stuff they'd be like no you
got to go to a
state where we get a discount or a
rebate or whatever so that's how we
wound up in minnesota for
mall rats um then we got to shoot chase
and amy all around here which is great
uh the only other movie other than
clerks that was filmed almost
completely in new jersey there are some
manhattan scenes and
chasing amy but generally we spent a lot
of time in jersey doing it
dogma we didn't that was in pittsburgh
jane's on bob strike back we had three
days here
including out in front of quickstep the
rest of that was in los angeles
uh [ __ ] jersey girl i didn't even
really get to shoot in jersey a little
bit in pallsboro but the most of the
time we were based out of philadelphia
and stuff
so i've never been able to you know
replicate the experience of i made an
entire movie in new jersey like i did in
the beginning of my career
which was my dream to do for the rest of
my life and stuff
so it's nice after the heart attack and
almost dying and chill like that to kind
of bring it full circle and be like okay
we're home
there is a point of contention about
whether we'd be shooting here or in new
orleans because
in new orleans we replicated the quick
stop at jay and sam bob reboot
so much so that when my daughter came
here for the first time to do vegan
about a couple weeks ago
um i was like what do you think she's
like oh i've been here before i was like
no you haven't
and she was like yeah we shot a movie
here i was like in new orleans
and she was like oh my god you're right
i've never been to the real place
so it looks convincing as [ __ ] so we
could have gone there and there would
have been a big rebate and stuff like
that
but i fought real hard to shoot here i
was like come on man just give me this
like [ __ ] that heart attack could
come back and i could drop dead
i want to drop dead in jersey if that's
the [ __ ] case let me drop dead on my
movie set in new jersey and stuff so
we got to come back here uh we did get a
state rebate and stuff which is nice
that also made it possible
um but did i think i'd come back i never
thought i'd leave in the first place
but i always knew that i would come back
for like clerks three i've been trying
to make clerks three for like seven
years
um the good news is that this
incarnation of clerks iii
takes place at quick stop the other
incarnation of clerks 3
barely touched quick stop it was
destroyed in hurricane
sandy so they spent the rest of the
movie someplace else
this version is i wrote a completely
different version in january
and this one's more predicated on the
heart attack that i had i take my
experience and i give it to
randall which in many ways makes this
clerk's
more personal experience oddly enough
than clerks too clerks is insanely
personal because i literally lived that
life
and said those things and that was my
whole world clerks too is a fabrication
i never worked at a fast food joint and
stuff
um i never had like my friends leaving
me or something like that all the stuff
that happened in clerkston i never went
to a donkey show once
so like all of clerks 2 is a fabrication
more of a movie and i love that movie
don't get me wrong it's one of my
favorite things i've ever
done but like there's personal things in
it but at the same time that's not
ripped from my life that's a guy going
oh what would those characters do if
they were in someplace else
whereas when those characters were
written the first time they were written
for like what would i
do what did i do clerk's three oddly
enough is closer to clerks one and as
much as we're back at the convenience
store which is somewhere i did work and
stuff so that's factual but more
importantly my experience
i get to give to my characters this time
around not just the heart attack but
they also get to make a movie
so in a weird way it's incredibly
[ __ ] personal in the way that the
first clerks was
um but it has all the kind of feeling of
of clerks too
uh so it's been an interesting ride to
get to this moment but i knew we'd be
back here sooner or later
um especially like when we on the j and
sam bob river road trip tour that was
when i
saw the space and i was like this is
open we should [ __ ] do something with
this and ernie was like i could build
this and that's where spodcastle came
from
and we didn't do that like on a lark i
did that knowing that i was going to
come back here i did that knowing that
we were heading towards clerks 3.
so it's wonderful to be back i've been
spending
every day walking the hills and
highlands my hometown
replicating the walk that i used to take
from my home uh on 21 jackson street up
to
henry hudson regional and then um
walking beyond that because it's not a
long enough walk like
i my whole life i thought like man it
took me like 45 minutes to get to school
i took this walk [ __ ] 15 minutes from
door to door and i'm like
so i barely [ __ ] broke a sweat out
and [ __ ] so i had to extend the wacom on
that but it's been beautiful because
everywhere i look there's a [ __ ]
memory you know i don't have that much
when i go to other cities to shoot a
movie and stuff
you make memories because you're like oh
this is like pittsburgh i've been to
twice since the first time was on dogma
made memories there and then when we
went back on zach and mary made new
memories and then those memories were
never shoot a [ __ ] movie in the
winter in pittsburgh
big mistake so uh so with this though
like i'm walking back into [ __ ]
memories it's not like i've been here in
years like i come back all the time and
stuff i'm overly familiar with the area
but now i get to hang out normally i'm
here for like we got three days we're
doing an event and then we're back on
the plane we go home and [ __ ]
now it's extended stay so i just get to
roam around i get to like walk into
stores
that i haven't walked into since i was a
kid and i get to walk into stores that i
never walked into
before i [ __ ] i'm a vegan and [ __ ]
but i was so i didn't buy anything but
like what
sabato's the [ __ ] meat store in
belford with the cow on the [ __ ]
roof i've driven past that place my
entire [ __ ] life because my parents
like we had pizza parlor in highlands
called francesco's and [ __ ]
but there was a place called the touch
of italy in belford
and they put a coupon in the asbury park
press every week for a three dollar
large pie
and so my father would put all of us in
the car and drive us [ __ ] from
highlands to belford
to get a cheaper pie and i'm like you
just blew that money on gas you know
what the [ __ ]
so um like going back there i you know i
never went into the meat store and today
i was like out and about and
earlier it was a day or yesterday i was
like no it was early this morning after
i took the long
i [ __ ] walked in for the first time
and [ __ ] and i was like
i'm done and then i walked out you know
just sometimes you just like to have
those experiences
and [ __ ] so it's been wonderful
wonderful being here and we
rehearse uh this week we start monday we
rehearse from like noon until five every
day
um and then uh we're off to the races
and uh
on a week from monday on my birthday
august 2nd my birthday gift to myself is
like let's start the movie
um so it's been great but did i think
i'd be back here oh god yes
and again i never wanted to leave and
[ __ ] but i was married to somebody who
was not from new jersey
and who spent three years in new jersey
and was like if you don't take me to los
angeles i'm leaving you and i was like
let's go to l.a and
uh she moved to l.a and i you know i
just
i wanted to continue having sex with her
so i also moved to la is what it comes
down to
thank you for that give it up for the
question man
all right ernie hands in the air
let's see if ernie finds you the eye of
sauron falls on you what's your name
uh it's rory rory give it up for rory
man you never
you never meet enough rory's you know
any worries right now
you might be my first word yeah i think
nice to meet you there's a few of us out
there
yeah like one or two gilmore oh calhoun
no i wasn't saying you're i'm saying
rory gilmore is a gilmore girl
uh nice to meet you rory calvin um
so um one of the questions i had for you
um was
what it kind of feels like to follow
characters for so long get to actually
see them grow through the
um you know portion three different
films and the other thing is um
i actually just started a film
production company which was like one of
my dreams yeah
and i actually got to um get like our
llc and got everything moving
so we were really excited but when i
knew you're here today
i was so um it was so important for me
to
meet you because you were so like
instrumental
and me just like getting to the point
where i am right now thank you for that
so i really just
act it's just such a stupid dorky thing
um i had some
cards made up and for like for the
company business cards
yes that's how i started that makes you
like that isn't it
it's throwing your hat over the fence
it's yeah like i'm [ __ ] doing a thing
so i better print up cards the first
step on
not everything you do but in film for me
i was like we have to get business cards
then i'll be serious
and we did and we were we we actually
just shot a film
last year oh congrats which was super
cool
and um i just kind of wanted to give you
that as like a thank you for
getting me like motivated to want to
write when i was like
12 13 when i started watching your
movies
oh my god what the [ __ ] who let you
watch that [ __ ]
kind of representable believe it or not
i actually i actually just like lost um
my mother not too long ago
no but she she um she did seem all rats
and she lost it every time when jane
sound bob beat
up the easter bunny so yeah that was
your mom's my kind of people yeah
she was super cool like that but um i
just really wanted to
get that out to you because um it's just
like a weird
kind of thank you i'll carry it in my
wallet man it's a
raven made out of film i was kind of it
is a very cool picture
i mean i would hold it up and nobody can
see this far into it and [ __ ] i'm
totally gonna keep this in my wallet and
then leave it at the scene of a crime
thank you so much man what was the
question though oh the question and
i'd asked you um so you had these these
characters that you started off with yes
almost like 30 years ago yeah
oh yeah and not a lot of filmmakers get
to follow
characters that long and just getting
ready to film
um i hope it's not the finale but if it
is the last time that we get to see them
what was it like watching them grow
from like say just being like early 20s
to being where they are now like
what does that bring out of you um
michael after the filmmaker
who made uh coal miner's daughter
amongst any things one of my favorite
films
he was a documentarian as well he made a
series of films called seven up
14 up 21 up where he interviewed these
kids
and seven years later he interviewed him
again for a whole documentary and then
seven years later when they were adults
he did it again he did he passed away a
few years ago
but he did another iteration of it
right before he passed away and i always
thought that was wicked i was like oh my
god he gets to check back in and you get
to see everybody grow up
um richard link later of course uh did
the before sunrise before sunset
and then what was the third one called
before midnight before midnight
series so you know i when he did
before sunrise like after that we did
chasing aiming
and then he did before sunset
but i didn't do another chasing amy you
know what i'm saying he kept going he
did those three movies and they're real
[ __ ]
beautiful because again like you said
you get to follow those characters and
generally
when movies are you know follow
characters again and again they're just
sequels
but this is like extending the story you
know
it's not a cash grab to make [ __ ]
before
sunset you know it's not cash grab to
make [ __ ] clerks 3.
nobody wants to see this movie except
myself you know so
it's um being being breathing that
michael after there
you know breathing that air where you
get to like go back
and play with those characters i you
know i just take it for granted because
if i had had my way i
just would have made 29 clerks movies
like i wouldn't have made anything else
i would have been like dante randall do
this dante randall
dante randall go to space but um
josh dr josh rouse you know the other
yesterday
um where i was talking about all the
[ __ ] negative comments and people
coming after me and [ __ ] like that
and uh you know i was i was not like
[ __ ] depressed but i was definitely
like a little quiet because you know i'm
like oh man i don't [ __ ] want people
to be mad
and josh you know was giving me the old
pep talk of like what the [ __ ]
like you're kevin [ __ ] smith and i
was like i don't want to be that today
did you see these tweets they all hate
kevin [ __ ] smith and stuff
but he pointed out he's like you're
about to make a [ __ ] trilogy
like you know how many filmmakers dream
about [ __ ] being able to do that make
trilogy films that are connected and
[ __ ] that is very uniquely theirs
like that spans decades and when he said
that it really
was like yeah that is that's kind of
[ __ ]
neat not everyone does that and i i i
you know i'm sure a
bunch of them don't want to do it
they're like i just like chris nolan
is never like oh i'll do the [ __ ] you
know um
was the memento trilogy you know you
know he does
if chris nolan lives in the future you
know he don't even talk about the past
go find an interview he talks about
memento not anymore
like meanwhile find an interview where i
don't talk about clerks
but um i you know even though there are
people like chris dolan who are like hey
man moving forward bigger better
um i think there are a bunch of
storytellers that would love that love
the opportunity to be like i'm gonna go
back i'm gonna
check in with my characters and stuff
and it's not financially viable
or [ __ ] you know maybe the movie
doesn't warrant [ __ ] uh
taking another financial risk or
something on just like [ __ ]
thank god lionsgate went for it and [ __ ]
i was like holy [ __ ] what
what a lucky day we did business with
them on jay and style and bob reboot
they had the home
video um and they had dvd and we sold
like a [ __ ] ton of dvds and i was like
dvd still exists
but we sold so many dvds and blu-rays
that they were like look you got
anything else like this [ __ ] and it's
under 10 million bucks you [ __ ] come
here
and i was like oh i got a [ __ ] under 10
million bucks
here's clerg's three and they're like
done so luckily we got them to come
aboard and stuff
and and i get to do it but you know it's
for me i was always gonna follow dante
and randall
throughout their lives um because
they're my parallel right that's why in
clerks three
they're making a movie like dante and
randall made my life so much better
dante and randall were the doorway to
all my dreams coming true
dante randall literally gave me this
life that i've been enjoying
professionally for 27 [ __ ] years the
least i can do
is return the favor to dante and randall
and be like here
you make a movie let's see what happens
gave them their
their lives you know in clerks too where
they figured out we'll buy the [ __ ]
store and be our own bosses and this is
where they get to evolve
like one more time and stuff um and you
know clerks was about
life in my twenties clerks two is about
life in my thirties
this one is about life from forties and
fifties 50s so-called
end of life and stuff like that uh so
there's poignancy but it's funny as [ __ ]
jay
jay muse has some of my favorite lines
he's ever had
in a movie in in clerks iii and we just
spent like a whole movie with him as the
lead in jay and sam and bob reboot and
he was wonderful absolutely wonderful
but
let's be honest jay and son of a hub are
meant to be used as like rosencrantz and
gilman stern like it's a shocking
that they've carried two [ __ ] movies
by themselves
never should have [ __ ] happened but
like in the clerks 3 they literally
played a similar role that they played
in clerks so there's like dollops of
them and it's really good and they're
there throughout the entire story and
stuff
but it's not like every [ __ ] scene so
i
you know i love it i love going back in
and and checking in with my
my kids and stuff and i can't wait to
share this story again clerks 2 was one
of my favorite things i've ever done in
my life
like definitely top two um so i
i can't wait to do this because as as
much as i like clerks too i
love what we got going on in clerks
three so i can't wait to [ __ ] share
it
i mean you talked about uh you know how
few filmmakers are lucky enough to get
to complete their trilogies and i just
can't help but think about
george lucas last i checked only got to
make two phantom menace
[Laughter]
i never got to see the rest of the story
somewhere george lucas is watching the
show going why is orco group such a
[ __ ]
what do i ever do to him you do better
george do you george
uh i don't know why does orca not like
my movies
[Laughter]
now now do orgo telling george that you
do like his movies i
like your movies george do you like the
one with watto
[Laughter]
no i feel competitive with other flying
blue guys
magic all right uh
castle keeper ernie o'donnell let's pick
our third and final
question answer of the evening so we can
let these people
go into that good night look at you
sitting down for doing it
it's only because me and him are really
good friends nice what's your name
ryan mcginley ron ryan mcginn ryan and
we'll give it up for ryan
all right thanks
all right ryan pull that mask up oh
sorry no worries
um if you shut down clerk's three a lot
of people will be [ __ ] mad ryan i'll
be mad at me
over your nose oh sorry there you go all
right um
so i have two quick questions but before
that i just want uh clerks
in my opinion is the holy grail i think
was great and a couple of us were
talking outside
and i said how clerks too it was awesome
in its own way where you don't need to
see
one to see two it's kind of it's like a
selfie it does kind of
work so because if you never saw one
even though you should
you don't need to the movie stands all
on itself without having to piggyback so
that was cool thank you uh two questions
i had one
is it going to be in black and white or
is it going to be in color it's both
so happy in the no not even
the premise of the movie of course is
that they make a movie so the movie they
make is in black and white so the
movie's in color
and when they shoot their version of
clerks which is called inconvenience
it's in
um that was the original title for for
clerks that was the first title of it
and vinnie vinnie pereira
will be coming back to join us he'll be
in clerks three as well um
he was the guy that's uh he was our cat
wrangler in the movie
uh but also he's the guy that comes up
to the counter and he's like uh
congratulations
you know she's marrying an asian design
major and dante's like so i've heard
that's vinnie vinnie used to live here
and leonardo lives in detroit now
um or in michigan rather i think very
near detroit
but uh he was the one that wanted to be
in film before me he knew
like he wanted to be a director and i
remember being like you can't be a
director you have to be born in
hollywood
and he's like no anybody could be a
[ __ ] director i was like really are
you sure he was the first guy that made
it clear that like
i could be a director he never said you
should be a director in fact vinnie
still says you probably shouldn't direct
but he was like uh the the guy that made
it seem possible
uh for me so why was i telling this
[ __ ] story
you're interesting no not right now what
was your question
hold on i'll just take me back to it um
i don't remember either
black and white oh the black people
thank you very much oh inconvenience
that was more it so when i
presented vinnie with inconvenience the
script which essentially is clerks
um vinnie goes ugh that title
so [ __ ] precious and i was like
really
like i thought it was clever he's like
it's [ __ ] obviously clever he's like
we gotta come up with a different title
for that
so vinnie like worked in the video store
and i worked in the convenience store um
he had been the mop
boy at the convenience store at quick
stop and he only took that job because
he
aspired to work in the video store and
finally the toppers one day [ __ ] gave
him the job and he thought his life was
complete and sure
so he was working on the video store i
was working at a quick stop
and he came in just like dante and
randall somebody always locks the videos
to her door and just goes and hangs out
a quick stuff
he came over he's like i wrote a list of
titles for for the movie
and it was a joke list of titles with
like very ridiculous [ __ ] names like
[ __ ] twister 2 and [ __ ] like that
like
but one of the titles was rude clerks
and we laughed so hard because it's like
so on the nose and so obvious and [ __ ]
like that like could you imagine it was
called root clerks
and then like 20 minutes later like i
went next door to the rst and i was like
but you know like just calling it clerks
is kind of cool because that's what they
are and he's like that's why i wrote the
obvious title and i was like yeah but i
think
it kind of works like i think we should
go with clerks and it was clerks because
of any
so why did i tell that [ __ ] story in
the first place
it goes back to the thing you said that
triggered all this
black and white yes so thank you so
we're saying about the
inconvenience inconvenience yes so the
the black and white movie they're making
is called inconvenience that's their
version
of clerks and it's you know i don't
it won't be around for a year so even if
i spoil some [ __ ] people will probably
forget but like
there are a lot of us replicating
the scenes that you know insanely well
like from clerks
and the beautiful thing is they're
replicated with
all the same people and we're all so
[ __ ] old
with the exception of castle keeper
ernie o'donnell uh ali who's our uh
wardrobe person the costume designer um
did a fitting with ernie and sent me the
pictures
and you know ernie if you don't know
played uh rick darris
in clerks you know i'm a trainer that
guy so
he's back in clerks three and he's
wearing the exact same [ __ ] outfit
that he wore
in clerks and you know ernie kept all
the pieces so it's all there nice
the the sweat box like uh sweatshirt
hangs in the secret stash but he's got
one of his own he's got the weight belt
he's got everything
so she sent me pictures of ernie and i'm
like this dorian
gray [ __ ] looks younger than he
did in the black and white movie we shot
[ __ ]
over 20 years ago ernie's got like
[ __ ] these amazing jeans also he
doesn't drink and it's [ __ ] smoke
which he's such a commercial
for [ __ ] not drinking and smoking he
looks so young so everyone in clerks 3
is going to look older except for ernie
yeah
who ruins the [ __ ] curve and like
when he shows up people in the audience
gonna assume like
oh that must be the son of the old man
who played that part and he's dead or
something like that no
it's just [ __ ] ernie he did a great
job on that he was like the perfect
cocky jock that i remember from like
high school he was just waitress and
kind of a bully one of my favorite
deliveries
in any movie i've ever made in my entire
life comes from my first movie and it's
from ernie where he goes
ah don't take this the wrong way but i
used to [ __ ] her
it is mind-bendingly [ __ ] perfect
perfect [ __ ] delivery
um anyway wait did you even ask a
question or i just start talking
black and white or color um
are you guys gonna get a film at night
uh because the store has to be open
during today
one thing normally what a [ __ ] great
question normally when we made clerks we
all
shot at night because like the story we
couldn't disrupt business
when we have come back to shoot clerks
ii the few scenes we shot here in jersey
for clerks too because that was shot
mostly in buena park
or the few scenes we shot here for jane
son and bob shrek back
the toppers have always been gracious
about letting us shoot in store with one
condition we cannot close the store
so we'll be like an action and we'll do
a take and go cut
and then mrs toppers like open the door
and people come in to shop
like walking past the cameras and the
actors and [ __ ] like that
and then they'd buy their [ __ ] as soon
as they were gone we'd be like all right
lock the door and
action you know this time around the top
is being really sweet about like closing
the place for two weeks so we're setting
up
um a satellite version of quick stop
called of course quicker stop
um in honor of the cartoon at the end of
the building so
you know there are some things that the
town can't do without lottery
uh cigarettes apparently candy i i was
like we're gonna have to bring milk and
rajiv who runs the store
who owns the store was just like you
don't need milk i was like what are you
[ __ ] kidding me like milk is a staple
everyone buys milk here
you know and i was remembering when i
used to work there he's going nobody
buys milk anymore
he's like you know i basically uh he's
like i make about
250 bucks a week on milk i was like are
you [ __ ] [ __ ] man it's like 10
gallons of milk he's like well done
and then he goes well done if we were
still in the 90s
that was the last time i rang [ __ ] up so
we'll be uh
doing our satellite version of quicker
stuff so people the locals can still get
stuff
but we get to close the store down so
there's been this interesting discussion
about you know since we're in utter
control of the environment
like when do we shoot things and oddly
enough even though now we have control
and could shoot all day long
we're going to be mostly shooting nights
um just because like it's the summer
times very hot it's very humid of course
and august's gonna get worse so rather
than shooting in the blazing heat of the
day it's just like let's kind of do it
at night
like so you know we have the benefit in
the script that the steel shutters
being closed so as long as you stay away
from the open door
it looks like daytime in that story that
was brilliant at the end of reboot i
i laughed so hard i got a cramp when jay
goes
he's like i've been putting gum and
locks for 30 [ __ ] years
yeah yeah we tag up on that again and
that's great clerks 3. trust me
there's no joke we don't tag up on in
clerks 3.
like if you thought reboot was like oh
my god this is like him trying to do a
best up album
uh this is me trying to do a double
messed up album
a lot of reference very much is that
good
uh yeah just just the last thing i want
to give you props it's great that you're
actually doing it at the store obviously
you know being in la you probably could
have built a set for probably
less engineering not in l.a it would
have been expensive but louisiana
anywhere really but you didn't do that
and i think it'll
i think every everybody else will
appreciate
it just you know what it is very hitting
back to home
i agree with you the beautiful thing is
like this was never intended obviously i
just wanted to make a movie but like
after a quarter of a century the place
is iconic like
it's on websites people come visit every
damn day from all around the world buy
gatorade take pictures in front of the
register in front of the sign
yeah you bit by gatorade right the [ __ ]
on man i was talking about you
um so and so you know
it's the place is iconic like it you
know it's lived
fine without me ever since you know the
last movie we made here and stuff
um but now you know we get to kind of
put a fresh coat of paint on the plate
which we literally did a few months ago
and head back in so um it's it's gonna
be fun because there will be people
you know who don't follow my [ __ ] all
that closely but do
like oh i want to take a road trip to
that like quick stop and [ __ ] they're
gonna show up and we're gonna be sitting
there making a [ __ ] movie they're
like did they ever go home
but thank you yeah it's so good to be
doing it here man this is where it all
began so it's like
you know it feels right coming home so
to speak
um that was the q and a portion of the
evening ladies and gentlemen give it up
for the q and a or just give it up for
ernie
may i be so bold
when rory not gilmore asked this
question it reminded me of an anecdote
you talk about seeing your movies too
young and i it feels
uh it would be stupid not to share it
here in the castle in front of these
people
but uh i
went to a sleepway camp for the first
time i was 12 years old
where you're supervised but you're not
super supervised this is not
charging the camp you talked about
earlier second camp second camp and
people here when i
[ __ ] talk about summer camp on mike
but uh
it just seems that you've went to a lot
of [ __ ] times too much of my life
but i go sleepway camp for the first
time the people in charge of you are
like 17 18.
so suddenly rules are off right and
there's a guy who i've talked about to
you
who was named grunge who was sort of
like my older like mentor older brother
kind of counselor training dude and his
two favorite things in the world
were kevin smith and masters of the
universe
he dressed like you backwards cap
[ __ ] trench coats
in the middle of the woods in the summer
and people said take the jacket off
he went no it's sound bob thing it's a
sound bob thing um and i
i thought up until that moment when are
he man and kevin smith ever going to
collide other than in this guy's brain
but he gets me both into
motu and into your work he was the guy
that kind of exposed me to both like the
older sister and almost famous playing
the record right
and excellent thank you so i go i go
back home
and i'm like uh hey i want to buy all
these toys and they're like those toys
have been out of production for 20
[ __ ] where are you going to buy these
i
want to see kevin smith movies like
you're 12. sit down shut up right
and then uh 9 11 happens right
and uh strike back had just come out
like right before the end of august i
think
it's a [ __ ] please let me just
absolutely not non-starter non-starter
non-starter
i think it might have literally been
september 12th if it was not it was
september 13th it was that soon after
and i lived in downtown manhattan and
when the tower was there
oh yeah not in the towers but yeah i
would guess
yeah yeah i was in town i born and
raised grew up there my whole life
and when the towers went down they
blocked off
like 14th street couldn't go above or
below right i went to school in the
upper west side
my parents couldn't get up to pick me up
from school another parent had hung
around because she was kind of a
helicopter mom
who lived downtown she was like i got
the kids and she's arguing with the
firemen you know because you're going to
have to stay in a hotel you can't go
below 14th street
dartmouth kids they need to go home to
their parents and go okay get home
and uh you know i'm the oldest i'm 12 my
brother's nine my sister's
three uh big gap there but
uh weird weird [ __ ] time right big
gap because they figured out like if we
send this kid to camp we could [ __ ]
again
yeah yeah absolutely yeah right they
were like 12
old enough for griffin to go to camp
maybe also the younger one as well let's
get them
both out of the house take the
three-year-old with you yeah
um but uh uh yeah i remember get home
and
my parents uh there was a video store
directly across the street couch potato
and they had rented every [ __ ] movie
that we loved that
they used to hate all the [ __ ] they said
we couldn't watch it's like here's
everything i'm saying
because they just didn't want the news
on they want to distract us they're
trying to plan
good plan good plan right so the next
day two days later whatever is the 12-13
i'm at home i think i'm watching my
brother and my sister and
my parents are out probably stocking up
on supplies because we're like is the
world going to end the store's gonna
close what's gonna happen here right
and uh we can't go to school shut down
we're stuck below 14
what are we going to do my dad calls me
and he goes
uh tell james to get dressed i'm going
to take
both of you to see jay and silent bob
strike back and i said
i've been trying to convince you to take
me to cj and silent bob strike back
because i'm a very mature 12 year old
he is nine and despite the fact that
i've spent the last three weeks
downplaying how inappropriate this movie
is
[Laughter]
i'm now gonna flip over some cards and
say you should maybe not
take him to see it and my father with
with a graveness i
have not heard since said griffin
i need you to understand that these are
extraordinary times
and extraordinary circumstances and i do
not want you
to question my parents in here
now go to camp he takes my brother and i
to
i believe it was the then lowe's theater
on broadway in 19th street
and the movie starts in two minutes in
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] mother [ __ ]
and he without missing a beat turns my
brother and goes you know we can leave
james you don't like this right we want
to see
this for the last 20 [ __ ] years
whenever my parents fight
my mom's always got that in his her back
pocket you took a nine-year-old to see
jay and silent it was 9 11.
they were extraordinary times and i go
look i told you not to do it
[ __ ] beautiful give it up for
gryffindor ladies and gentlemen
um the uh this week i think
uh we'll be releasing on the youtube
channel as well
uh we did uh masters universe uh
revelation celebration
commentary tracks so for every episode
there's a commentary check so the first
one i do by myself
second one i do with dia who wrote
episode two a third one i do with mark
who wrote episode three
fourth one i do with tim sheridan he did
four and the fifth one of course with
eric carrasco
um so hopefully you watch the show first
because there'll be lots of spoilers and
whatnot but it's deep dives
into the episode with the writers who
wrote you know those words those
scenarios and giving you background on
where that stuff came from and stuff
hopefully it doesn't piss more people
off online
i uh you know like i i i yeah i'm so i
wish
people didn't get upset but i'm sure
those people like well i wish you made a
better [ __ ] he-man
so you know fair enough um to those
people who didn't like the show
um i'm sorry but again just wait
there'll be another [ __ ] he-man
coming down the road if you don't like
this one and stuff
however this man will be around for a
minute humans like the mta
you know if you miss one there'll be one
in 15 minutes exactly you'll get another
one yeah this is reboot time kids like
they're gonna reboot it
sooner or later very fast on the heels
of our version and stuff but um
our village version still has more to go
five more episodes i don't know when
they get dropped they haven't told me
exact dates i'm not sure if it's the end
of this year
the beginning of next year and stuff
because they want to spread it out
um in
um in the in the in the
in the event there's a season two they
want the season two to happen in
2023 so you know they want to kind of
space it so that there's not missing
motu for
for too long or anything like that uh
i'm sure i'm getting [ __ ] fired and
not for
not for ruining he-man as i've been
accused of doing but like for
giving out far too much [ __ ]
information but i have been wanting to
talk about this show for so [ __ ] long
like for the whole time we were working
on and stuff so now i'm just like
um so look for those commentary tracks
well they'll go up on monday or tuesday
or something like that
uh they're really fun and very very
informative if you like the show at all
uh don't forget kids the jeff's kiss
shirt
available at jsonbob.com um
do you have anything to sell anything
excel blank check with griffin and david
wherever podcasts are found
uh this week we're talking old so if you
liked me talk about that for three
minutes you can listen to me
repeat myself for two and a half hours
uh
and then get ready to do uh the whole
john carpenter filmography after that
and i can't say
what because it's a spoiler but we got
you on the books for an episode early
next year we booked way too far in
advance so
anyone else would go we should get kevin
on when the show's premiere and we were
like can we get you on nine months from
now because we're unorganized
um yeah listen listen to that and and
watch
i'm i'm on a show called masters of the
universe revelation
we worked really hard on i'm very proud
of him um
the uh you know it's been
a wonderful weekend no lie uh but there
have been
moments of like oh man you know based on
um
like the you know some of the stuff
that's gone on online
uh but this was the bomb the
and i don't mean this is the bomb this
is the b-a-l-m the the
sav if you will the bomb for the heart
man sitting here talking to you
um for a person i did not even know one
year ago
you've become incredibly important to me
and my work so i thank you for putting
all your heart into that performance it
makes the difference
look a lot of people are saying horrible
[ __ ] about me
nobody's saying anything bad about orca
and that's because of you give it up for
griffin newman your goal
i do i mean
i hate the netpick but my first
recording session was february 22 that
was over a year ago so your
compliment is invalidated but you know
whatever fair enough i've known him over
a year [ __ ]
i didn't know there'd be notes uh no but
it's it's truly
you know uh people like kevin smith's
doing the he-man show what is how does
that line up and this and that and are
they smoking moss man whether i stole a
joke from someone else i'm sure
but uh i i i truly you know especially
because
uh even pre covid i was the only cast
member in new york city
came in handy for this today when i was
local
but i i was i because i know this
because the tony todd wasn't in l.a
really yeah and somebody else was in new
york as well
okay method man recorded in uh
new york that might be a biggest point i
mean
some guy recorded it oh my god
maybe i wasn't the only one but but um
when we when we started recording it was
right before you don't know who he plays
um hold on hold on clownfish please
don't tell anybody
please please i'm gonna get in trouble
if that gets out please don't tell me
um uh what we started recording it was
right before the pandemic and i was sort
of bummed where i'm like all right
everyone else gets to be in studio
working with kevin and
oh my god mark hamill in the waiting
room oh what a weird coincidence
whatever and i'm like here in my own
little
corner and then very quickly the world
changes and we're all doing it over the
screens
you know but we have had this uh weird
relationship
over screens and that can feel very
impersonal as i think all of us know
because we were forced to live that way
for far
too long but you all and we're heading
back to it i know yeah apparently right
i thought this was an epilogue's
intermission
but uh uh i'm sorry too dark too dark
too dark fingers crossed
everything's good it's gonna get better
um but
uh yes you always made me
feel like i was in the room like the
thing was hands-on like everything was
normal
and uh very supportive and it was it's
such a pleasure to work on the show
we liked it yeah we had a great time we
did uh ladies and gentlemen
of uh the residents temporarily
of smod castle for this episode of fat
man beyond did you have a good time this
[Applause]
evening
i cannot thank you enough uh for coming
out and whatnot uh
please uh a big round of applause for
uh ernie o'donnell our castle keeper he
built this place for you
um we got christian in there on the
soundboard give it up for christian
wayne on the door made sure he got in
safely and what not give it up for wayne
uh but especially give it up for a
stellar
stellar [ __ ] guest man like i love
content generators and goddamnit
and he generated a lot of content not
only do you give us great performance
with words that were written for him
this is probably the longest i've heard
you extemporize
and i'm like he needs no writer
whatsoever this was like half a blank
check episode i regret to inform you
uh yeah i could go all night and then
people go like
you could have ended a couple hours ago
quit while you're ahead um we won't
we'll be
probably doing the show uh still me and
mark
you know the the kind of streaming
version but we won't do
uh it in person for the rest of the
month or all the month of august because
we'll be shooting the movie
but there will be a fat man beyond just
not the in
in person live shows um that being said
we only opened up spot castle like three
weeks ago and we got to do
uh the show three times so far batman
beyond and it's been absolutely lovely
lovely i can't thank you enough for all
coming out
and supporting the place man this little
dream come true and [ __ ] and everybody
come through
makes it thrive keeps it alive it's so
nice pulling up and seeing people
in front of the block of stores you know
when i used to work here as a kid
if i would have seen 50 people outside
the store i would have been like i'm
dead
but um but it's so nice seeing people
like you know in the [ __ ]
uh setting sun just hanging out in front
of the quick stop building waiting to
come in here and do a show so thank you
for uh letting me make my dreams come
true right here in this corner of the
world and as soon as we're
done making the movie we're gonna reopen
smod castle and have lots and lots of
shows
um so until then uh ladies and gentlemen
that oh you know who i forgot to [ __ ]
thank is dr josh roush back there give
it up for josh roush as well
and now that is fat man beyond for this
week man
i'm kevin oh wait holy [ __ ] bam
jumped in you're in new jersey for three
weeks and you forget about me already
next thing you know mark's gonna be out
there and you're never coming home
and i'm left here by myself on saturday
afternoons
give it up for jc gentlemen without j.c
we got a show man
himself and for what it's worth
masters of the universe which i saw at
your house i re-watched
all of last night and it's a time
machine for me
it brings me back to like 1984. right
what's up you one of the toy kids did
you have the toys
i love the toys i have pictures of my
brother and i
because we were too poor to have real
power swords we had like the cheap
knock-off ones
playing he-man in my backyard it's one
of my favorite photos when i'm
four and he's two so it was it's a time
machine for me i love it so thank you
thank you my friend that that last piece
made it
okay that you [ __ ] interrupted the
end of the [ __ ] show
um there it is kids that is fat man
beyonce this week i'm kevin smith
i'm mark bernardin newman
tune in next week same that time same
fat channels podcast.com
or youtube.com kevin smith
jeff's kiss everybody have a great night
good night
you